welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is Eric Trexler I am the
special temporary primary host of the
show and today I'm joined by Greg
Knuckles he is currently the permanent
guest co-host for the time being Greg
thanks for joining me thanks for having
me on how are you doing today doing well
how are you I am doing well because I
unlocked a new experience in life do
tell uh I was
in San Jose California I was on a
podcast which by the way
we really need to upgrade our podcast
situation I know you are on Dave Tate's
podcast I was uh a guest on mind pump
uh I walk in there's a team of people
diligently working around the clock to
make that operation work the studio is
all like soundproofed with all these
different cameras and microphones there
was a producer there uh rather than the
on-air Talent producing it as we go they
got a real a real operation going on uh
leaves a lot to be desired when I come
back home
well uh as the person who heads up the
podcast uh
I would say that ball is firmly in your
court yeah I saw a bunch of uh Twitter
threads about
um
CGI companies who are really upset with
their working conditions I think we
should just lean into it and do like a
half CGI situation and really boost the
uh the quality I think that would be fun
that'd be cool yeah like really make it
a multimedia production but anyway not
the point of the story uh I was in San
Jose and I experienced my first like
substantial earthquake like I think when
I was younger at some point in my life I
heard that an earthquake occurred I
don't remember if it was in Ohio or
North Carolina
um but you know there it was like Hey an
earthquake happened but you probably
didn't feel it and I was like yeah I
didn't feel it yeah so I was sitting
there in San Jose and I mean like stuff
on the walls was like shaking and moving
and I was like whoa this is for Real so
there's a magnitude 5.1 earthquake uh
that happened about 12 miles away was
the epicenter uh so like you know a 5.1
isn't like a crazy crazy magnitude but I
was looking up stuff and apparently
values above five are pretty pretty rare
even in the Bay Area and in California
obviously California is known for having
a lot of earthquakes just because of the
the tectonic plates over there uh but
apparently in the last 30 years in the
Bay Area they've only had uh like three
or four earthquakes that are that are of
that magnitude uh so even for the locals
it was a bit of a a bit of an atypical
experience
um and apparently just for for frame of
reference I like to kind of put it into
units that people kind of know better
than just like a Richter Scale so about
20 million kilograms of dynamite if
you've ever felt uh that type of uh
energy release that's about what we were
talking about in terms of the seismic
activity yeah so I uh I I don't know
what what 20 million kilograms of
dynamite uh sounds like or feels like
but I do have some secondhand experience
with dynamite
um not going to share yeah don't admit
to any crimes I'm not going to share too
many details here because I I don't want
to accidentally get anyone in trouble
but uh someone I know
um used to be able to legally get their
hands on Dynamite and they had a large
tree on their property that they that
they wanted taken down and like we're
we're talking about like a huge tree
absolutely enormous the type of deal
that is certainly not not amenable to
just like a chainsaw yeah
um so it would be the type of deal where
you know you need to get some some
forestry folks out
um it would have been quite expensive
would have been a whole rigmarole
um and you know he he wasn't taking it
down just for fun like the the tree was
starting to like Decay die whatever like
it needed to come down
and so uh he looked at his options and
determined that it would be
far cheaper and more efficient to Simply
drill a hole in the tree stick some
dynamite in and blow it up
um so that's what he did and I was like
kind of a long way away like what you
know not like a hundred yards we're
talking on the scale of like
um maybe like maybe like a mile away you
ever take when it happened didn't know
it was gonna happen and like I mean it
was it was loud enough that it was still
quite scary yeah um and and apparently
if you were within like 100 200 yards
there was a notable shock wave like a
lot of energy release
um and I mean my first thought is is
growing up in kind of redneck country I
thought someone had gotten their hands
on
um like a one of those like barely legal
firearms that's like basically small
small artillery like it was pretty
serious
um but yeah I think that was just like a
stick or two so I imagine 20 million
kilograms would be would be really
really something yeah yeah so it was my
first earthquake experience uh you know
that was on the bucket list so I can
check that off uh the earthquake itself
I wasn't really worried
um but like so the earthquake starts
happening I'm like oh wow it's really
happening happening and I'm you know
kind of just observing and then I
remembered that tsunamis exist and I was
like where's the epicenter for this
um but yeah so fortunately despite the
high magnitude it doesn't look like
there was a ton of like damage or
injuries or anything like that that's
good but but uh it got me thinking about
um uh natural disasters and there was
one thing in my past that I kind of go
back to and it happened when I was a kid
so I think I was I guess I was like
eight ish years old and I remembered as
a kid there was like a big uh tornado in
my town and I was like I wonder if I can
find any information about that just to
like understand the scale of what
happened because when you're a kid you
blow everything out of proportion your
hometown is the whole world in your eyes
so so I was like I wondered like if
there's a way to kind of contextualize
uh how big that was so I Google it
thinking maybe I'll find like a local
newspaper story that's like archived on
the internet
there was a Wikipedia page for the for
the the tornado that hit my hometown
when I was like eight so like if
anything I find I found out that I was
under selling it in my childlike mind
um but yeah I looked it up and when I
was a kid there was uh like a a storm
system that came through that spit out
like 54 confirmed tornadoes and I think
three of them were f4 on the tornado
scale which I believe goes up to F5 uh
but yeah I mean there were like hundreds
and hundreds of buildings just destroyed
uh I think the damage estimate here is
82 million uh for which for for a little
like not little but you know with
tornadoes you don't necessarily
anticipate such widespread damage with
that type A lot of times like if you
live in an area that doesn't have a lot
of tornadoes a normal tornado situation
at least in my experience growing up in
Ohio is the storm conditions are right
for a tornado to occur and so everyone
says hey look out there might be a
tornado what do you do with that
information
frankly not much yeah because it's just
like a wall of clouds and it's like one
might pop up somewhere we don't know
maybe it'll touch the ground who knows
and it'll last for like a little bit of
time and then just disappear
um but but anyway uh yeah so
I normally you know it'll just kind of
drop down you'll see the funnel cloud
you know something will happen and it'll
take out like a few houses on a street
or something or like you know really
significantly damaged just a small
little area broadly speaking um but
every now and then you get these systems
that kick out a ton of tornadoes and
some of them are huge and they'll really
really cut through a town so uh yeah
looking back at it I I kind of didn't
understand the scope of the natural
disaster one because I was a child and
two because I slept through the entire
thing nice I just woke up and my parents
were like yeah you don't have school and
I was like why and they're like
look around like
Take a Hint man like like there's like
200 buildings damaged here but uh so
Greg uh natural disasters what do you
got for us have you been through any uh
yeah the the biggest one it was also an
instance of sleeping through something
um my wife and I were on an anniversary
trip when uh when Hurricane Matthew was
coming through a few years back and you
know we we could have rescheduled it but
we had already had to reschedule it uh
because when we were trying to go for
our actual anniversary uh got in an
accident totaled the car ended up uh not
taking the anniversary trip then so we
had to reschedule it we ended up
rescheduling it during Hurricane Season
thinking like ah you know North Carolina
generally gets hit by about one
hurricane per year so what are the odds
it'll be that weekend anyway turned out
to be that weekend
um but we we said you know what we have
a we have a summer anniversary
um already rescheduling for like October
it's not really an anniversary trip if
we reschedule for like February and also
it was kind of the the furthest extent
of like the beach actually being like a
Beach vacation you know like once you
start getting into November and it's
cold it's a whole different vibe so we
said whatever like we're still gonna do
it uh and it looked like it looked like
at the time the forecasts were saying
that Matthew was gonna Arc back out into
the ocean but it ended up just going
right over us like the the eye of the
storm passed over us thankfully it
wasn't that big of a deal
um I believe Matthew peaked as a
category 5 hurricane but it was I
believe it was like a weak category one
when it went over us wow um yeah I I
slept through the whole thing we were in
the kind of like back half of the storm
wall when I woke up the next morning and
the wind was so loud it sounded like
someone was running like a lawnmower
right outside our window I was like what
is what is going on it's ridiculous we
look outside and it's just you know like
it was kind of the outside part of the
storm wall so I think it was like 50 60
mile an hour winds
um and you know it there there wasn't
really any danger but certainly if there
had been it was it was passed by that
point so it actually ended up being
being a very cool and fun experience
because For the First
the first maybe like two hours of that
morning when we were still like in the
in the last little remnants of the storm
wall
um like it was just like pretty
consistent 50 to 70 mile an hour wind
which is I mean it's it's whipping but
like it's not going to take you off your
feet
um so we just went outside and hopped in
a hot tub and it felt like just chilling
through the apocalypse like you look
around the sky looks insane uh we could
see the ocean some of some of the most
ludicrous waves oh yeah we could see
sometimes when the wind shifted
Direction uh the water would like blow
out and the waves would break into the
ocean instead of into the shore which
that was a crazy sight to see yeah um
and yeah we're just sitting in the hot
tub just kind of observing everything
and uh yeah that that was fun
um like it was I would say like two
percent scary and 98 just generally
interesting uh then for something that
was
um
quite a bit scarier I would say
is I I went to college in Arkansas which
is also Tornado Alley and we had
um
like every year we were there we had
multiple tornado warnings I think only
one tornado ever actually touched down
on campus but it just kind of like just
plopped down on the quad for a second
destroyed one of the oldest and most
beautiful trees you'll ever see and then
just left like it was as if it had a
grudge against that particular tree yeah
and then just moved on with life yeah
and that that's what I was getting at
though it's like when that happens
there's like they'll be they'll put out
a warning for like seven counties yeah
and say like hey this might happen where
we don't know and yeah it just drops
down and does it but is is kind of like
a a second hand thing related to that so
they're you know there were tornadoes
all the time in that area
and my first semester there
um so for for people listening who don't
know I went to a Christian School
um and so we had Chapel every day which
uh as not a morning person wasn't really
my preference but you know it was what
it was and during
um like during my first semester there
uh there had been a hurricane that had
torn through uh Community like you know
pretty close like just a little bit down
the road and it had completely destroyed
the elementary school and so one of the
first chapels of that semester they they
were kind of taking up a collection like
raising money to help them rebuild the
elementary school like very very nice
good thing to do so raise money they
rebuilt the school couple years later uh
guess what another another band of
tornadoes came through destroyed the
school again this was like junior year I
believe and so once again uh we have a
chapel uh and I'm pretty sure no one was
like I don't think like kids were killed
in the school these were tornadoes that
came through at night destroyed the
school when when people weren't in it as
far as I remember
um but yeah so another Chapel uh raised
some more money to help rebuild the
school
um you know all good they rebuild the
school
and then I want to say well that's good
though because I mean if a tornado hit a
school twice you know it'll it's not
going to get hit a third like there's no
chance that it would get hit a third
time well I think you see where this is
going uh like two years after I
graduated thereabouts
um like I was still on the Harding
mailing list and we got an email saying
what do you know another more tornadoes
came through uh and would you believe it
they destroyed that same elementary
school again
um so you know same general process and
on one hand that's you know that's
obviously sad like it's it's disrupting
those kids learning
um
also it's obviously very nice that every
time this happens uh Community pulls
together raises money
um it's also nice that that Harding was
willing to chip in because like Harding
itself is a quite well-endowed school
um and a lot of the surrounding area is
very poor like very constrained like
local budgets and whatnot so it's it's
nice that that they were willing to help
out but there there is just like a bit
of of dark humor and irony there where
it's like you know it's
it's God's will that we should try to
collect money to help rebuild this
school but
maybe maybe it's actually God's will
that there not be an elementary school
in that exact spot
um
who who knows who knows yeah uh but yeah
so that that was that was kind of a a
second-hand natural disaster type
experience yeah and I should clarify
since people actually listen to this uh
if you are in a place that gets a
tornado warning and you don't know how
tornadoes work uh you should ideally get
to like a basement or a seller you want
to be underground and if you can't be
underground you want to be on the lowest
floor possible and get to a building
with really firm walls inside the the
structure so usually like people will go
to a bathroom that's centrally located
in their home because the walls have
Plumbing running through them that kind
of reinforces it uh so I I don't want to
be the person who convinces people to
take no action when they get a tornado
warning and that's that's good
information for us to have as well you
you uh inform me of this recently
apparently Tornado Alley is moving East
it is so we we thought we were getting
out of it but you know 20 30 years from
now we might we might be what we might
be able to put our our prior tornado
experience uh to good use we might uh
hopefully not but we might uh okay so we
have uh we have to sell out really quick
here uh that's really the purpose here
we just want to show these various
products and opportunities so if you
like rate if you like the show you can
support it many different ways number
one you could like rate or subscribe
wherever you access the show uh if you
like free weekly newsletters with
research updates everybody likes that uh
get on the email newsletter sign up for
our email list it goes out every week uh
nice fresh update with new training and
nutrition related research updates you
can do that at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter if you're looking for
one-on-one online coaching you can find
that at Stronger by science.com coaching
if you want a discount on your
supplements you can get them at
bulksupplements.com using the discount
code SBS pod for a five percent discount
uh if you like the kind of content we do
you can get more of it every single
month in the mass research review We
published that the first of the month
every month along with uh Dr Mike zordos
and Dr Eric Helms and uh if you're
looking for a food logger or nutrition
app that does have built-in coaching
functionality to kind of help you decide
what your macro Target should be uh
check out macro Factor we co-developed
it and you can do a free trial so you
can take it for a spin and see if you
like it before you make a financial
commitment and we do have two great
segments today but first we need to
fully complete the process of selling
out we're going to take a quick timeout
for an obscene profit break
foreign
as the first and only Fitness podcast
with a steadfast commitment to
traditional Family Values we know that
protecting families is important right
you are Eric but I will note there are
some things that are even more important
than protecting traditional family
values and the moral fabric of our
society that's right Greg it's important
to protect families but it's even more
important to protect corporate entities
that's why I joined the Advisory board
for the Sports Nutrition Association
Along with trusted Fitness Pros like
Danny Lennon and distrusted arch nemesis
like Eric Helms the Sports Nutrition
Association is the home of Sports
Nutrition they are dedicated to ensuring
the sustainable prosperity of the Sports
Nutrition profession and they offer a
unique Pathway to robust insurance
coverage for your Sports Nutrition
business simply put it's the best way to
protect the corporate entities that are
closest to your heart and I should note
if you're an individual soul proprietor
providing Sports nutrition services and
not a corporate entity the Sports
Nutrition Association can help you out
as well that is correct all insurance
plans are handled individually on a
case-by-case basis regardless of how
your Sports Nutrition business is
structured but even if you don't want
insurance coverage sna membership comes
with a bunch of other perks and
advantages the Sports Nutrition
Association is the only Global
professional sports body that has a
defined standard for Sports Nutrition
scope of practice for its members this
ensures that members maintain high
standards in their practice so that the
public can always trust in the quality
associated with the services of an
accredited Sports nutritionist through
the Sports Nutrition Association if you
already meet their minimum education
requirements you can become an
accredited Sports nutritionist today if
you don't meet those education
requirements yet you can enroll in the
certificate program in a applied Sports
Nutrition that allows you to become a
provisionally accredited member upon
completion
to learn more about the Sports Nutrition
Association head over to
www.sportsnutritionassociation.com today
today's episode is sponsored by the
Sports Nutrition Association and
stronger by science LLC sincerely
appreciates their support
alright so Greg moving on to our
segments here what do you have for us
today yeah so
um I have a
um
how how to describe this segment so I
used to do a little segment at the top
of the show called Rude to the stage uh
documenting my my weight loss uh
progress and I recently uh ticked off a
nice little Milestone
um I am officially below 220 for the
first time since
August of 2012 I believe so that's
that's good feeling good awesome quite
happy about that and so I wanted to do a
little segment
talking a little bit about some of the
things that have helped me out along the
way uh with with that process because
you know I I've uh quite quite publicly
been a a larger man in the public eye
for uh for I mean over a decade at this
point
um and have quite publicly struggled
with weight loss in the past
um
and
a a good chunk of my uh ongoing success
this time around has been in
ah
you know like so one of the
one of the uh frequent things that I
would see said about me on the internet
previously was you know like why should
why should I listen to anything that
this person has to say about nutrition
if you clearly just looking at them they
don't know anything about it like don't
know what they're doing which like
honestly I get it you know it is what it
is
um but a lot of the the the journey to
where I'm at now I think a lot of what
has helped me is not so much like
learning new things about weight loss it
has been
unlearning things that I used to think
were like absolutely necessary and
mandatory
um that in a lot of contexts are
probably good advice but that
when applied without care and context
can I think sometimes do more harm than
good so I I wanted to talk about that a
little bit uh in this segment so
um yeah the title I have for it is
popular weight loss advice that may do
more harm than good
um and just to add a little Nuance to
that uh you know things that that are
probably in a vacuum pretty decent
advice but
um you know can that have a non-trivial
risk of of leading people astray when
applied without context and so to be
clear I'm not talking about like scams
or like fad diets or anything like that
um you're not gonna do a whole segment
on the grapefruit diet here correct yeah
yeah so I'm talking about things that
are uh the the sort of advice you would
hear from generally well-informed and
well-intentioned evidence-based Fitness
professionals that like I said in a
vacuum might be very good advice but
that I think are sometimes presented as
blanket must-haves that might might not
always be the case so I I think
um I think what I'm getting at will
become more clear as I get into this
segment
um and also uh so just to just to kind
of start out with some some context and
background for where
a lot of the dietary advice in the like
so-called evidence-based Fitness
Community originates and I mean really
just the broader Fitness community in
general
um a lot of it kind of
uh originates with or gets popular with
bodybuilders and physique athletes first
and foremost uh which which kind of
makes sense
um so four four people who are
bodybuilders physique athletes like a
huge part of the sport is pursuing what
uh what Adam Fisher our buddy Adam uh
does support for both Stronger by
science and macro Factor great dude got
absolutely diced in this past year but
what he terms exotic levels of leanness
um and you know if that is your Pursuit
if a if a big part of your sport is just
getting as peeled as you can possibly
get it makes sense that you're more
likely than the average person to just
like stew on the approaches that might
be best suited to accomplishing that
that Pursuit because you know that's
that's a huge part of your sport uh and
when you're trying to reach an extreme
goal uh the details simply matter more
you know what I mean yeah um and I also
think it makes a lot of sense for
for just kind of the general fitness
public to look towards bodybuilders
physique athletes bodybuilding coaches
physique coaches four General nutrition
advice
um you know even if like there there are
reasons you might not want to but just
kind of like on a very basic level it
makes sense because you know if if
you're
like that is a population of people who
reliably and predictably Achieve extreme
levels of leanness like that's a huge
part of what they do and it's it's
pretty rare for successful bodybuilders
to
sign up for a show and just show up
completely out of shape you know they're
they're able to pick months in advance
hey I'm doing a show on this date and I
need to be incredibly Lean by that date
and then they get there and I think that
that's extremely appealing for a lot of
people because you know the the thought
process is if they can so reliably and
predictably get that lean
and I have you know I I'm only trying to
get down to 15 body fat or like for
um for the women listening like you know
25 body fat something like that like if
if they can get that peeled then their
advice certainly has to be good enough
to help me get to where I'm trying to go
on a reasonable timeline you know yeah
and we see that with other domains as
well uh where like you'll you'll see uh
people who are like trying to get tips
for running their like one person sole
proprietorship type business and they're
like I'm gonna read a book by someone
who runs a Fortune 500 company with like
70 000 employees about how to manage a
company and it's like well yeah like
those strategies certainly can help you
manage an enormous company but you might
not necessarily need that for your sole
proprietorship or for like a tiny
business that has like two contractors
yeah yeah for sure so
um yeah a point that I'm going to
attempt to make in this segment is that
some of that advice
might be unnecessary at best or
counterproductive at worst for people
who aren't pursuing as extreme of goals
and just as one final like little bit of
framing before diving in
um the context of this segment is I'm
talking about people who are trying to
lose a significant amount of weight and
keep it off so I'm not necessarily
talking about advice for people who are
going into a weight loss attempt with
the intention of kind of doing cyclical
bulks and cuts you know you're gonna
lose 20 pounds trying to get super lean
and then you're gonna regain 20 30
pounds in the off season to try to build
more muscle and then get lean again you
know like a uh which I'll note like
that's also like a kind of common piece
of advice a lot of people give
um
which also just directly comes from
bodybuilders which I I don't know if
that's necessary for everyone but people
with those sort of of uh
who are intending to take a cyclical
approach to Weight Management that's not
really what I'm talking about I'm
talking about folks who are trying to
lose you know 10 20 30 pounds and keep
it off in perpetuity yep
um so uh yeah with with that out of the
way let's dive in
um so ultimately uh I I think a
successful weight loss diet kind of for
that purpose lose the weight and keep it
off uh is going to need to have three
characteristics uh one you need to be
able to stick to it uh to help you stay
in an energy deficit for a long enough
period of time to lose the weights you
want to lose number two uh it needs to
support other goals you have Beyond
weight loss per se you know like if
you're working out you need to have
energy for working out trying to
maintain muscle you need to be able to
maintain muscle needs to be able to gel
with your social life to some extent
um all of those things and and number
three and perhaps most importantly
certainly very important uh whatever you
do needs to set you up for Success at
the end of your diet because again
you're trying to lose the weight and
keep it off so it's not just you know
trying to Sprint to lose 20 pounds and
then you just find yourself on kind of
the yo-yo diet roller coaster lose the
weight gain it all back you want to be
able to to build the necessary skills
and lifestyle around what you're doing
that when you lose weight you'll you'll
be able to maintain that and keep it off
so the the first uh idea I would like to
talk about the first piece of popular
advice that I think often uh might might
be okay advice in a vacuum but that
often does more harm than good when just
given as blanket advice to everyone is
uh the pursuit of rigid macro Counting
and I'm not going to get super in depth
on this because I know I know you've
talked about this on the podcast uh
quite a bit before but uh I'll note on
the front end
that a rigid approach to macro counting
uh makes a lot of sense for bodybuilders
in in a lot of contexts so first the the
general rigidity of it
um you know having uh carb fat protein
targets that you try to stick to every
day with minimal or ideally no
deviations from them that makes a lot of
sense when you're on a strict timeline
where you need to get super diced for a
show on a particular date you know yeah
um there there is an end to date for
that diet and you better get there
otherwise there's not much room for air
and and you just kind of make a fool of
yourself on stage
um which you know that's that's not what
you're doing you know so uh the the
rigidity uh like a rigid approach to
macro counting
um can certainly make a lot of sense for
bodybuilders from from that perspective
uh and also just the approach to macro
counting in particular so you know not
just not just trying to keep an eye on
say total calorie and protein intake but
really trying to keep an eye on each
particular macronutrient having carb
targets for the day fat targets for the
day and really not trying to to deviate
from them much at all
um I also think that makes a lot of
sense for specifically bodybuilders
trying to get super lean so protein
obvious that's going to help support uh
muscle maintenance or you know maybe
even gaining a little bit at the start
of the diet need to have plenty of
protein uh fat makes sense like having
having a strict fat Target Fat's
important for absorbing fat soluble
vitamin women's
maintaining hormone production Etc and
carb intake also very important you need
energy to fuel your training and the
thing is if someone is trying to get if
someone is pursuing exotic levels of
leanness you find yourself with very
little margin for error at the end of a
diet you know like you're not going to
be eating as much of anything as you
would like to but you you might be
dealing with something where if you
don't hit like your fat Target is really
low your carb Target is really low and
if you eat
10 more grams of fat than you had
allotted for yourself well now carb
intake is so low that you're already
shitty training session is just going to
be even shittier you know or what's that
saying is it robbing Peter to pay Paul
exactly yeah when when you're dieting on
a bodybuilding context toward the end
every time you add one macro you're like
I'm paying for this somewhere else yeah
yeah exactly and the in the inverse as
well like if you you know if you eat 30
more grams of carbs than you were
supposed to and that comes out of your
fat budget you might be looking at weeks
at a time where you're you're really
consuming such low fat intake that it's
quite unhealthy you know so the the
really really
um strict uh approach to macro County
and really focusing on each Macro makes
a lot of sense in that context
um but I think that that can that can be
counterproductive for a lot of folks who
have other goals
Beyond just getting diced for for a
bodybuilding show first it's just
generally unnecessary
um like our our general perspective is
that for most people just tracking
protein and total calories is fine most
people's hedonic preferences will wind
them up with enough fat intake to
support fat soluble vitamin absorption
hormone production enough carb intake to
support training
um
and you know you're you're not going to
be uh finding yourself in the sort of
situation where everything is just so
low that those trade-offs get uh really
extreme
uh also like the the uh idea of really
rigid macro Counting
we like you've talked about this a lot
before the difference between rigid and
flexible cognitive restraint
a lot of people refer to all macro
counting approaches as flexible dieting
because you have a lot of flexibility
with food choice but if you're
um you know if you're pursuing
three numbers that you have to hit every
day with very very little room for error
um that that just gives you a lot more
opportunities to fail and lose
motivation
um and uh it an in-depth discussion of
maintaining motivation over the course
of an entire diet that's probably a
little bit outside the the scope of this
segment
um but just in kind of broad terms
if you're setting goals for yourself
that are challenging but achievable and
you're hitting them consistently that
can help build and sustain motivation As
you move forward
um but you know if you're putting
yourself in a situation where you're
setting goals and targets for yourself
that aren't strictly necessary for the
pursuit of your goal and you're giving
yourself more opportunities to at least
perceive what you're doing to to be
failing you know if if you're saying man
I gotta get within 10 grams of my carb
Target and five grams of my fat Target
every day while maintaining some
semblance of a normal life that's going
to be quite challenging a lot of people
who aren't
you know pursuing a diet with the
single-minded focus of a bodybuilder
like a lot of times you're just not
going to do that and then you feel like
a failure and then you might hit the
kind of [ __ ] it point and say well I
already went 10 grams over on my fat
today is already a failure so I'm just
gonna eat everything inside because I I
already failed today like that's that's
the situation you can find yourself with
with really rigid cognitive restraint
and it's just not necessary yeah I think
the term you used there was the [ __ ] it
Point yeah yeah in the research I've
seen the what the hell effect and I'm
I'm wondering why they went with with
that one instead of your preferred
version I mean it it the similar
connotations I would say no it's exactly
the same thing but one is more printable
in textbooks yes
um
and then yeah uh finally like it
um
like so with with kind of the framing
device three things for an important
diet you can stick to it supports your
goals Beyond weight loss per se and sets
you up for Success at the end of your
diet I don't know that uh losing weight
with really really rigid macro counting
necessarily does a great job of setting
people up for Success at the end of
their diet because
it does take a really rigid cognitive
restraint to do it and most people don't
want to do that forever you know like if
if you're able to pull it off for 16
weeks six months whatever you might very
successfully lose the weight that you're
trying to lose but most people don't
want to come within five grams of a
protein carbon fat Target every single
day for the rest of their life you know
so if that does sound like something
that you would enthusiastically do for
the next 50 years then go for it but if
you look at that and say damn I really
don't want to do that every day for the
next 50 years then this might be an
approach to weight loss that that
ultimately isn't setting you up for
long-term success because it's not
uh like the the skills you're developing
to pursue that type of diet aren't the
skills you would need to then be able to
kind of transition to a more normal way
of eating and and ultimately keep the
weight off yeah if I could add a couple
things here yeah yeah go for it number
one you mentioned that a really in-depth
discussion of like uh meeting goals and
supporting or facilitating uh motivation
sustained motivation is a little bit
outside the scope of this particular
segment there's two articles I would
direct readers to uh one is strongerby
science.com
slash goal setting and the other is
macro factorapp.com cheat meals uh both
of those go into more detail about uh
sustaining motivation uh motivational
collapse in the context of overeating
and rigid dietary targets and things
like that so I would recommend that for
further detail if anyone's interested
another thing
I think a lot of people might be
confused when they hear this and say
okay well I've looked at the literature
and it says that for long-term weight
loss success uh you know some form of
dietary tracking and just general
monitoring practices seem to be
correlated with success in the long run
and so so people might be hearing this
and saying well what gives if if
monitoring is is facilitating long-term
success why would very precise
monitoring be perhaps not the best
approach and ultimately I think if I
could draw on an anecdote uh I was
helping out with a study where that was
a collaboration with a weight loss
clinic and we would have you know
basically participants would come back
when they hit a certain marker when they
kind of Hit the next milestone in their
weight loss and it was starting to
become really clear the people that were
like cruising through it and the people
that were really struggling and you you
know as a researcher you're in the room
with them right you you have the
opportunity to to chat make some small
talk and kind of pick their brain a
little bit and one of the things that
jumped out to me was the really
successful people who were cruising
through it and maintaining it long term
they were doing a lot of the basic
monitoring practices that we talk about
they were keeping an eye on body weight
and they were tracking consistently but
not rigidly and I think that is the big
distinction that you're getting at here
is you want to track consistently but
you don't want to be super rigid about
hitting three exact numbers precisely
for the rest of your life and
when I talk with these folks what they
seem to do broadly speaking
is fall into a comfortable pattern where
they're consistently checking in on body
weight uh not hyper fixated on it but
just keep an eye on it you know
um and they are tracking their calories
uh maybe tracking protein as well this
population wasn't doing a lot of lifting
so the protein was kind of secondary
yeah
um but you know what would happen is if
they started to see weight creeping up a
little bit then they would say oh that
that's interesting maybe I need to
tighten up my tracking a little you know
and and get it from kind of cruise
control into like hey it looks like
things are starting to drift a little
bit I'm aware of that early because I've
been monitoring body weight and now I
can take my tracking Precision from uh
seven out of 10 to an 8 out of 10 or a
nine out of ten and for most
applications you really don't have to
crank into that absolute highest gear
where you're precisely and rigidly
tracking carbohydrate and fat and
protein protein unless you're trying to
get to to that term you've been using of
exotically lean yeah yeah and also I
mean like unless there's
uh unless there's a date at which you
have to achieve a certain body weight or
a certain physique or anything like that
um even just like adherence to the
targets is more of a
uh more of like a fuzzy concept instead
of just like you have to hit the numbers
dead on the head every day so like you
know as as an example if if someone's
trying to lose about a pound a week give
or take
um you know that's that's going to come
with an energy deficit of around 500
calories per day on average or so
and so ultimately if you say need to
lose exactly 20 pounds in 20 weeks to
get to you know whatever physique you're
trying to achieve for a bodybuilding
show then like yeah you need to achieve
that deficit every single day or that
cumulative deficit every single week to
get where you're trying to go
at the exact date you need to get there
if it you know if it's more about
long-term weight loss and hey like what
you know I'm gonna get there eventually
and then I'm gonna try to stay here and
maintain it for the next 20 years or
whatever
um that's that's just unnecessary you
know if there's a day or two a week
where you just say you know what there's
a lot of other things going on I have a
social event coming up I just don't feel
like being in a deficit today you can
just eat at your maintenance intake like
one or two days per week for the week
you're still in a cumulative energy
deficit it's still going to be uh moving
you towards your goal maybe not at your
intended rate but it's still ultimately
progress you know or
um like I this is also something I see a
lot just when when people discuss this
uh on the internet where you know maybe
their daily calorie targets like even if
they're not tracking macro super super
rigidly their daily calorie Target is
like 1700 calories or something then
they're trying to lose a pound a week
and they're like ah man like I I hit
1800 calories today I hit 1900 calories
today I feel like a failure but it's
like dude like that's still a a 3 400
calorie deficit like it's that is that
is still a a directionally appropriate
thing you did and I think that if if
folks were able to take a step back and
you know adopt a mindset of flexible
restraint instead of rigid restraint
that they would see that that is still a
win like this was still a very good day
um you know perhaps not the absolute
optimal conceivable day given what I'm
trying to do and the rate I'm trying to
do it at but it's still good and and I
think with the with the really really
rigid restraint
um you you find yourself in a situation
where you end up reframing small wins
into unqualified losses and that is that
is not a recipe for Success no I mean
that's a great example and it reminds me
one time I was working with a client and
and there was just stuff going on in
life where really meticulous tracking
and pushing the deficit hard just wasn't
really in the cards for a stretch of
time and I could tell they were starting
to get a little bit disappointed with
some of the you know like ah I haven't
been losing weight lately but weight
loss was the goal and it was starting to
kind of get internally framed mentally
as failure and my biggest thing was like
well wait a minute let's take a step
back
we're like 17 kilograms below where we
started yeah maintaining your weight 17
kilograms below where we started is an
unqualified success yeah no so like even
if you do run into those areas of
friction I know we're talking about a
slightly different thing here in terms
of time scales but like yeah I mean if
you were shooting for a 600 calorie
deficit and you hit a 250 calorie
deficit you're still in a deficit you
know if if you were hoping to lose
you know three pounds this week well
that's not a good example but you get
the idea yeah you you set the goal of
what the optimal Target is but like if
you're still directionally moving in the
right place or way further along than
where you started it is important to
kind of take a step back and look at the
broader the broader picture and say it's
really hard to call this a failure yeah
yeah absolutely so
um like I said I'm I'm talking about
this because the excuse I'm using is
that I I recently hit that weight loss
Milestone and so like for for my
experience with this diet and plenty of
diets that had failed in the past
um I I did previously do what uh I
thought I was supposed to do you know I
I
um I I know a reasonable amount about
nutrition I could calculate like what my
protein Target should be
um you know how many carbs I needed to
support the training I was doing the
rest come in from fat it was plenty of
fat to support vitamin absorption
hormone production I was like okay cool
like I've got my numbers I did all of
this the right way
um and now if I'm serious about my
results I just need to stick to them and
you know I I would do a pretty decent
job of sticking to them for a while and
then as soon as motivation started
flagging a little bit and I started
missing the numbers I would I would just
start to feel like a failure and just
kind of like hit that [ __ ] point
um whereas like for for this attempt
like I still have those same Ebbs and
flows of of motivation but there's been
no there's been no motivational collapse
um you know sometimes I'm losing weight
exactly at the rate I'm intending to
sometimes I'm still heading in the right
direction but at half of my intender
rate sometimes there's just a lot of
[ __ ] going on and I don't want to be
dieting I don't want to be in an energy
deficit uh and I mean that's coming up
holidays are coming up birthday
Thanksgiving Christmas New Year's dude
I'm not going to be trying to lose a
pound a week through all of that so uh
just take a break be in maintenance for
a while and and it's okay uh and so it's
set me up in a position where
um you know I can do a better job of
savoring my successes and it's more it's
more a matter of just kind of of
qualitatively assessing was this a big
win was this a small win or
um you know if I do go way over my
targets one day it's a learning
experience you know like
one day can't
it's impossible for one day to be that
big of a setback unless I allow it to be
a setback and snowball you know so yeah
um yeah just just uh adopting more more
flexible restraint has been huge so that
that first one uh went longer than I
expected it to but I thought that was a
good conversation yeah moving on though
this one will absolutely be short
because it uh more or less restates your
segment from the last episode of the
podcast where you were talking about uh
protein intake targets so the second bit
of advice that I think uh might be
generally good advice in a vacuum but
that sometimes can do more harm than
good when just applied as a blanket
statement is uh giving people or telling
people that they should select like
quite high protein targets
um
so like I said for for an in-depth
discussion of this uh dear audience
referred to the previous episode
um but yeah with with high protein
targets
um for bodybuilders it can make a lot of
sense like taking a better safe than
sorry approach to protein intake
um because protein intake is very
important for maintaining muscle mass in
an energy deficit and it gets more and
more important the leaner and leaner
someone gets if you're going from you
know 40 body fat to 35 percent body fat
at a you know reasonable rate of weight
loss you got a resistance training
stimulus in there you don't have to
worry about losing muscle when you're
taking off the last five pounds before a
show and going from eight percent to
five percent body fat
then you probably do need to worry about
it uh quite a bit more and uh you know
again the whole point of the sport is to
be as muscular as possible and as lean
as possible and so if if you can uh if
eating a little bit more protein can
help you maintain an additional half
pound of muscle over the course of a
diet that you know that could be the
difference in placing it at a show so
um it makes more sense to kind of give
people uh better safe than sorry type
protein targets and um yeah I mean for
for most people there there just aren't
those same sets of concerns so uh like
we talked about in the last episode well
I say we like Eric talked about in the
last episode
um the difference between a protein
Target of like 1.2 1.3 grams per
kilogram and say 2.2 grams per kilogram
or above
just doesn't seem to be partic
particularly large or
particularly uh
we don't super consistently observe that
there even is a difference to begin with
in the literature like yeah if you start
getting down to a gram per kilo or below
like that certainly seems like it will
probably have deleterious effects for
the amount of muscle you'll maintain if
you're in a deficit the amount of muscle
you'll gain in a surplus but you know it
it seems like pretty pretty moderate
protein intakes probably get the job
done pretty well for most people most of
the time
um and you know if so previously again I
I used to just use that old heuristic of
a gram per pound just 2.2 grams per kilo
um
and and I really found that that just
didn't work for me
um
so
uh
one of the one of the big considerations
here again with just like a successful
diet is you need to be able to stick
with it and it also needs to accommodate
the rest of your life and it needs to uh
set you up for Success at the end of a
diet and I found that you know when I
was trying to get more than a gram per
pound of protein that basically
necessitated a lot of chicken breast uh
a lot of protein shakes and just like a
lot of foods that I didn't particularly
like and like I I have it easier than a
lot of people do because like I'm an
omnivore like it's going to be harder
for a vegetarian or a vegan
um and like I also just don't have that
many social things I do but if you're
going out for with friends a lot to
restaurants and whatnot
um having a lot of meals with family and
you're trying to get in a gram per pound
of protein with a lot of food options
that are like fattier higher carb then
the choices you'll have to make to hit
that protein Target will probably be
reasonably incompatible with actually
staying in an energy deficit in the
first place and will often require kind
of trade-offs and choices that
that lock you into a diet that you
probably won't want to stick with for
the next 50 years you know it seemed
like you wanted to say something
oh um
I was just kind of smiling because I
I've heard of anecdotes where people
will be like in bodybuilding prep and
they'll be like uh yeah I want to go out
to eat with the family but you know I
have to this is especially people who
sit really really really high protein
targets and they're like yeah so I went
to this restaurant and I said boil me
two chicken breasts and then steam me
some vegetables and if if I even smell
butter near those vegetables I will walk
back into the kitchen you know like they
just create this like special order and
they spend like 30 dollars on the
absolute shittiest dinner they've ever
eaten uh so when you're talking about
how like a lot of times so a lot of
times people do kind of feel like
they're pushed into this situation even
outside of a restaurant scenario where
they're like okay it's the end of the
day or close to the end uh I feel
completely satiated I'm fine I don't
feel like eating but I've only had 1.4
grams per kilogram of protein per day
and therefore in order to hit my protein
Target I'm going to have another meal
just to check that box and in that meal
to make that protein palatable I'm going
to also bring in additional carbohydrate
and fat and and it can get to the
situation where it's like
that that was ultimately if the goal was
fat loss you probably didn't even really
need that extra bump from to get you
above 1.4 that day and you just invited
all these other calories that just
chipped away at your deficit for No No
Good Reason yeah yeah absolutely so you
know you're you ultimately do need to
consume enough protein like not trying
to state that protein intake is
completely unimportant but I do think a
lot of people myself included find that
somewhat lower protein targets
um
are just more compatible with the way
that they want to eat and the way that
they can see themselves eating for the
rest of their lives uh and you know not
most people don't want to live on a diet
of of protein shakes and uh boneless
skinless chicken breasts and broccoli
for in perpetuity yeah
um and I mean also man with with
inflation being what it is a lot of
protein-rich foods are are kind of
expensive so if uh if money's tight
dropping down from 2.2 to 1.4 like there
there might be some some non-trivial
cost savings associated with that as
well well no I mean you always hear like
especially like in in the U.S you hear
college-aged folks who are trying to
build muscle and they're like yeah I'm
trying to bulk but it's so expensive
the vast majority of that expense is
their protein yeah the vast majority
yeah absolutely so uh again like my my
issue with with this bit of advice isn't
necessarily the advice itself in a
vacuum my issue is more with how it's
often like framed and messaged
um so you know for example I think that
saying something like as long as you're
getting in about 1.2 1.3 grams per kilo
you're fine but aiming for 1.6 may not
be a bad idea uh if it's feasible for
you I think that's perfectly fine that
seems to be in keeping with the evidence
um it's not setting 1.6 grams per kilo
as a rigid and flexible Target you have
to shoot for uh but you know if if 1.6
or above isn't keeping with someone's
preferences
um you know it's I'm sure they don't
lose anything by by getting up that high
uh whereas the the way I often see it
framed is just you got to get in 1.6 to
2.2 grams per kilo and bad things will
happen if you don't and I do think that
uh the advice about protein when framed
that way uh has has the potential to to
do more harm than good yeah I think
that's totally accurate and one of the
things that made me smile is like you
had mentioned like a moderate protein
intake
um but but what's kind of convenient is
that this like 1.2 gram per kilogram
general area
like a lot of Americans end up there
unintentionally yeah like if you read
the public health literature sometimes
you'll get like these really panicky
papers that say Americans are overeating
protein and it's a huge problem and it's
like oh yeah we found that they're
eating like 1.2 so a lot of people who
are embarking on a diet might be at the
kind of tail end of this range just
based on their dietary preferences alone
and they might not have to really make
any major changes to get into that 1.2
range yeah yeah for sure uh all right so
moving on the the fourth uh bit of
advice that I think
um makes a ton of sense for bodybuilders
which is which is where a lot of this
stuff originates but may not be the best
just kind of blanket advice for people
to give or receive is the the advice
that I that I see commonly in a lot of
circles that if you're trying to set up
a diet to lose weight one of the things
that you should really try to prioritize
is eating basically as Bland of foods as
you can stomach
um
and so for bodybuilders that kind of
makes sense so with um so the the
thinking behind this this bit of advice
is that human energy intake is regulated
by a lot of different things but
specifically for for feeding Behavior Uh
or eating Behavior you have hedonic and
non-hedonic eating and non-hedonic
eating
um
seems to be in large part just kind of
your your body integrating a lot of
signals related to fuel availability
um satiety long-term energy status Etc
and trying to like tune your appetite to
consume enough calories for survival uh
but then you know we humans we're not
just uh you know we're not just
basically amoebas uh responding to just
cues from our environment about how much
we need to eat to survive we also have
uh food science and a lot of delicious
ingredients and highly processed foods
that taste very good that you want to
eat in large quantities and um yeah I
mean I'm sure everyone listening to this
has eaten more than they really wanted
to at some point just because the food
was delicious and that is hedonic eating
and
um yeah so if all of the food you eat in
your diet doesn't like really trigger
that hedonic response that can
that can help cut down on hedonic eating
and and large deviations from your your
dietary goals and targets and I think
that that is the sort of thing that that
can be quite important for for
bodybuilders as they're trying to get
very lean
um
because I think like I mean just from
talking to people who've been there like
your your brain can kind of get in a
state where you haven't eaten
much that's really tasted good in a long
time and when something very yummy is
put in front of you
a lot of people like even if they
generally have like a pretty pretty
normal relationship with food otherwise
just kind of uh
just attack highly palatable very
hedonic food like a feral animal when
they're like super super lean so so like
yeah like that's
um
it makes sense for that population it
gets different yeah so like uh there's a
great paper uh if I remember I'll try to
link it in the show notes but it's about
the uh participants in the Minnesota
starvation experiment and like it really
does get different when you start
getting really really lean like it does
like if you read that paper they don't
say oh when they got lean boy did they
sure get hungry it it's it's psychosis I
mean it is like psychological like
things are different you know like in
that study that they were like okay if
you want to chew gum just to kind of
have you know something in your mouth
and a little bit of flavor go for it and
then they were eating just dozens of
packs of gum a day and they're like okay
you can't do the gum anymore right they
would they would find that people were
just kind of so fixated on food and just
kind of like obsessing over uh thinking
about uh or you know like I've talked to
you know I've heard anecdotes of
bodybuilders who aggregate
and collect cooking supplies and recipes
that they know they can't use for the
next like four months
um but yeah there there are like really
uh pathological psychological kind of
changes that can happen
in the vast majority of cases they are
transient and acute and then once you
kind of get back into the swing of
things they go away but but yeah there's
for bodybuilders there is an application
of this because you will find that when
you're in that kind of semi-starvation
state and you have a really a level of
food fixation that's very atypical for
you and you kind of open the floodgates
by having okay I guess I'll have a bite
of that what you can't really put that
back in yeah you know once it's out of
the bag like stuff has a tendency to go
kind of Haywire yeah yeah absolutely and
and the other very important thing to
note is again with bodybuilders you're
talking about a time limited diet uh
you're you're really going to
uh cinch things down really tight for a
period of months to get in insane
condition for a show and that's it then
you go back to eating other stuff but
again if if the goal is to lose weight
and keep it off long term
that's that's not really what you're
doing you're trying to build skills that
you can transfer to the rest of your
life and so I think that um I think that
this advice can make sense if it's not
taken to the extreme so
a lot of people run into trouble with
over consuming like like hyper palatable
foods and a ton of just like really
really highly processed refined Foods so
I'm certainly not saying like oh yeah
like your goal when you're trying to
lose weight and keep it off is try to
figure out how you can be in an energy
deficit while consuming the maximum
number of Pop-Tarts possible like that
that's certainly not what I'm saying
um but I think that the value of
pursuing blandedness of food for its own
sake
um probably isn't a great thing to
pursue for a couple reasons one
is that for most people that's just
going to harm adherence with your diet
like we we live in a world with a lot of
food options and a lot of really yummy
food options and if you're a bodybuilder
and you're you know you know you need to
get on stage in Speedos in three months
and uh and look a certain way when when
that's like
you you need to look a certain way on a
certain date I think that helps a lot
with adherence like
because you you don't want to make a
fool of yourself in front of your peers
in the sport but I mean for for a lot of
folks if you say like hey I'm just going
to have the most bland food possible in
my house all the time and that's the
only thing that I'm going to eat on my
diet and then you stop in a gas station
and see the snacks you need to go to the
store you drive by a restaurant walk by
a restaurant whatever and there are just
so many other much much more delicious
food options there and you don't have
the same sort of like extreme external
pressure forcing you to adhere to your
diet uh then you're going to find
adherence is just more challenging
because everything else that is very
easily available for you to eat just
tastes better than than what you're
trying to force yourself to eat
um this is also going to conflict a lot
with social situations so if you're
if you get in the mindset that I can
only adhere to my diet and not go off
the rails if I'm only eating bland food
then like if you find yourself in a
social situation where you like quote
unquote have to eat more palatable food
like that that might [ __ ] with your head
a little bit
um make it easier to kind of go off the
rails and then lastly like again a big
theme Here is you're trying to you're
the process of losing weight should be a
learning process for developing the
skills that will transfer to the rest of
your life and I mean I I don't think
most people want to live on chicken
breast and rice for 50 years you know so
um there there is
the kind of a process you have to go
through of
whatever food you find like you know not
hyper processed not hyper palatable but
but tastes good like it's good palatable
food that you enjoy eating
um
like you you need to be able to
consume that in moderation and uh
find something you can stick to you know
so uh yeah the the fixation on just like
only eating Bland foods and just the
Bland of stuff uh that you can that you
can stomach I don't think sets uh most
people up for long-term success yeah and
there's one kind of assumption that is
uh usually tied to that recommendation
which is like okay you are doing a
bodybuilding style diet which means that
we assume that the the you know calorie
intake and macro intake is fixed right
and so then it just becomes well should
I try to eat really really tasty stuff
to hit that fixed set of macros or some
kind of more bland stuff and the thought
process is generally like well when
you're eating the really hyper palatable
stuff you're you're still eating the
same amount but it's just going to be a
tragedy when the meal ends you're gonna
be like I don't want to stop it's like
well why put yourself through that just
eat some stuff that's a little bit more
boring you're hitting the same macros
anyway way you know it'll just make your
life a little less painful for for this
short term kind of diet
um but when people try to use this
advice in a scenario where macros are
not fixed you know they're not going to
get on stage in 12 weeks so they're
they're like sometimes you'll see people
who say you know what
I'm afraid that if I eat that cookie I'm
going to eat 300 calories or 400
calories worth of cookies so I'm Gonna
Keep to the Bland chicken breast chicken
breast and broccoli and rice
and what they'll do is they'll eat a
serving of that and it clearly didn't
scratch the itch that they were going
for with that kind of hedonic feeding
urge yeah and they say well maybe if I
just eat more of this Bland stuff it'll
scratch that itch and it usually doesn't
um and so like one of two situations is
actually pretty common when food intake
is not rigidly fixed as it would be for
bodybuilders which is either in order to
avoid the 400 calorie cookie Splurge you
eat 400 calories worth of this other
stuff and in terms of energy balance you
end up in the same place yeah yeah um
the other is instead of get you know to
try to avoid that 400 calorie cookie
Splurge you eat like 300 calories worth
of the boring stuff and then say that
didn't really work I'm gonna have the
damn cookies anyway and then it becomes
additive rather than replacing so
sometimes people will think
I can basically tune out my hedonic urge
to eat by really leaning into eating
stuff that will satisfy satiety signals
and they're completely they're not
completely separate but they are
different they're distinct yeah and a
lot of times people think that well if I
just get full or nearly full I won't
have this hedonic urge to eat anymore
and that rarely seems to be the case so
in scenarios where calories aren't fixed
it's not just that this advice isn't as
useful it can actually sometimes
directly backfire in terms of just the
sheer amount of energy intake oh
absolutely uh and then so the the final
thing I have on this list of of advice
that uh I think is is sometimes good in
a vacuum in this case I think it's
advice that really is just good for
bodybuilders uh and really isn't that
good in a vacuum otherwise but but
certainly isn't helpful for most people
is uh a focus on the outcome of a diet
rather than the process of a diet and
particularly kind of time-based and time
limited outcome goals and
I I think that a lot of a lot of times
this isn't directly stated but it's it's
kind of tacitly implied by the sort of
content people put out and the sort of
advice that people give even if they're
not like explicitly saying to focus on
these things
um so you know in terms of focusing on
on outcomes this is a very visually
driven industry
um like people who talk about physique
stuff people who talk about nutrition uh
like there's this saying like your body
is your business card uh which should it
be I don't know maybe not but I mean it
is that's uh that if you're a
professional in this field uh and you
have a much much better physique than
most of your peers that's probably going
to help your bottom line and so it it
makes sense to put that front and center
um but you know what does that tacitly
communicate to your audience like it
tacitly communicates like looking this
way is is valuable and this is what you
should want like you should try to be
focusing on this outcome also just in
terms of how people sell their services
like before and afters are huge which
again makes sense like uh people like to
see someone who who looks similar to
them before and then you know four
months later they have a physique that
that they would kill for you know so but
again before and afters without further
context that is just a focus on the
outcome of of a diet not necessarily the
process
um
and then like the like it's still pretty
common to see people
um
who are doing like General General
Health and Fitness coaching with a
nutrition component
um do do challenges where it's like hey
I'm putting together a group and we're
all going to try to lose 20 pounds in
six weeks or whatever which again that
that is a focus on a time-based outcome
and I again I think a lot of this for
bodybuilders makes all the sense in the
world that is literally the sport you
start your diet on a certain day your
show is on a certain day you gotta look
a certain way by that day like the the
outcome the physique itself that is your
sport and doing it in a fixed amount of
time that is what the sport entails but
I don't think that is really helpful
advice to trickle down to virtually
anyone else
um the the time it does make sense is if
someone's a strength athlete and they're
trying to like cut to the next lowest
weight class because then it's sort of
the same deal you know you need to be
below certain body weight on a certain
date for for weighing in but otherwise
like yeah no that's that's just not uh
that's not helpful so I I do think that
I do think that it might be a little bit
useful on the front end because you know
people want what they want and they want
it now they don't want to
if you if you tell someone like hey you
can have the physique you want in four
months or we're gonna focus on the
process maybe you get there in four
months maybe you get there in two years
just as a sales pitch we're gonna get
there in four months is way way more
appealing but then once you actually get
into it
um it circles back to a lot of the the
things we've been talking about to this
point like if you're trying to lose x
amount of weight in X weeks and you fall
behind and and you really have a rigid
end date you know now you have created
for yourself a potential Vector for
failure where one doesn't need to exist
like if it's more of an open-ended thing
you're just trying to lose weight you're
and you're focusing on the process of
building the skills necessary to stay in
an energy deficit do it in a way that's
that's feasible and sustainable for you
building the skills to uh maintain that
weight loss at the end of a diet
um you know maybe you fall a little bit
uh behind schedule so to speak but
you're learning a lot through that
entire process and with a with a process
orientation rather than an out than a
outcome orientation it gives you just
more
more just room and Grace I suppose
um to to build those skills and to
interpret setbacks and falling behind
schedule and all of that stuff less as
um less is a failure less is an
indication that you are likely to fall
short of your goal of achieving a
certain look or a certain amount of
weight loss by a particular date or in a
certain period of time and it's easier
to reframe those as learning
opportunities like if you if you had
some strategies that had been working
well for you to stay in an energy
deficit everything seemed pretty
feasible and then just for for a week
the wheels fall off you're finding it
really really challenging to stick to
your your dietary targets you have a ton
of Cravings Energy's low uh diets just
really going poorly
um you can either step back and say oh
no like I'm trying to reach this goal in
12 weeks and instead of moving forward
for a week I've moved back for a week so
now I'm functionally trying to reach the
same goal I had before but only in 10
weeks because I just took a step back
and this week was already so hard like I
I I'm already regressing so like now I
have to be even more aggressive to get
where I'm trying to go on a certain date
and it like that that is that's not a
recipe for Success like it's it's no
wonder why people lose their motivation
when they when they have that mindset if
they hit any speed bumps whatsoever and
I mean news flash you're gonna hit speed
bumps
um but if it's more of like a process
oriented thing you're not quite as
focused on the outcome certainly not in
a Time limited space
you can step back and say hey this week
was [ __ ] why did this happen you know
um maybe some of the strategies that
have been working up to this point uh
are becoming less effective maybe it's
just other stuff going on in my life and
I need to give myself some Grace and get
out of the deficit be in maintenance for
a while like I I don't need one more
stressor in my life right now everything
else is crazy uh but I can take the
lessons I've learned to this point and
once things calm down use all of that to
get back on track
um it's it's just not
it's just not a helpful orientation just
the extreme time-based outcome focused
uh approach to weight loss
um but one thing that comes to mind is
that you know some people have asked us
why the default behavior and macro
factor is so for example if you go 400
calories over your Target on Monday why
don't they you know why doesn't that
pull that out a Tuesday or maybe pull it
out of like Tuesday and Wednesday and if
you want you can you can make the app
behave that way you know there's a way
to do it but it's not the default
behavior and it's exactly because of
what you said it's like in most cases
you know when when you had a Target and
you went well above it that means that
there might have been some challenge
leading into that that discrepancy
between Target and observed intake and
the last thing we need to do is say you
know how it was so hard to hit this
target yesterday that you went 400 above
it
guess what that challenge might still be
present but it's going to be even harder
because now in the presence of this slip
up we're going to tighten the screws
even more yeah and it's not just that
we're going to get back on the horse but
we're actually Shifting the targets
downward to make it even harder to get
there
um and like you said if you get really
locked into that short time scale
outcome focused time dependent goal you
start to put yourself in a situation
where it can become immensely
overwhelming and stressful yeah yeah and
I mean it's it's the same thing with how
uh like gold progression Works in macro
Factor as well like you know uh when you
set a goal uh the app tells you
essentially like hey if you stick to
this rate of weight loss or or weight
gain but we're talking about weight loss
in in this segment if you stick to this
precise rate of weight loss this is the
date at at which you'll reach your goal
um and I I think people I think some
users expect us to like enforce that end
date rather than the updates to be
informative like hey to continue losing
weight at the rate you want to this is
what you should aim for and they'll say
like you know hey I was trying to lose
um 20 pounds in 10 weeks and I'm five
weeks in and I've only lost six pounds
and the app isn't dropping my calories
really low to try to to try to get me
there by what I thought my end date
would be
um and it's it's kind of the kind of the
same deal you know if like diets get
harder the longer you do them and if it
has been like if if it was already a
challenge to lose 10 pounds in the first
five weeks like if you already fell
behind that that timeline
odds are pretty low that we could
increase the target rate of weight loss
by 50 percent and still get you to 20
pounds in 10 weeks you know what I mean
yeah
um and so yeah it like we like
ultimately we want we want success to
snowball but we want to be able to put
the brakes on setbacks before they can
snowball into like true robust failures
yeah
um and yeah I think that a really
outcome focused time-based approach to
weight loss inverts that
um where uh you know if you're if you're
rewarded for anything like getting ahead
of schedule
um you know that involves eating even
less than your targets losing more
weight quicker
um
and you know like you're you're
uh functionally rewarded for being extra
restrictive
and then if you fall behind again
because you were like it's just it's
just [ __ ] hard to stay in a
consistent energy deficit if you find
that challenging on the front end of a
diet if you then make the diet even
harder as you go along like you're
you're putting people in aggregate in a
scenario where
um you you can't get that far ahead it's
hard to feel that good about the success
that you're achieving but boy if you
fall behind instead of putting the
brakes on on those deviations and and
small failures like they can they can
really snowball into just full-on
motivational collapse yeah
um so yeah really the the point I'm
trying to make in in Broad Strokes with
this segment
is that I think a lot of the advice that
is given in the fitness industry from
well-informed well-intentioned people
tacitly has
kind of the underlying assumption that
food has little value for its own sake
that you'll always be able to stick to
your diet and that you're aiming to get
as lean as humans are capable of getting
so in essence
the advice kind of the the tacit
underlying assumption is if you
perfectly execute on all of these things
you will get diced
um and really the the optimal body
composition outcome is the only thing
that matters and therefore this is good
advice that you should follow and if
those assumptions are true
then yeah it's good advice that you
should follow but that is not how most
folks are you know uh food does have
value uh beyond the physique it can help
you achieve it tastes good their their
social value to it cultural value to it
um you know the the assumption that
everyone will always perfectly stick to
their diet that is quantifiably a bad
assumption so it's less about saying hey
I'm going to assume everyone listening
to this advice is robots and with that
assumption I will tell them how to
perfectly achieve their physique goals
um
those aren't the people in your audience
you know like they're it it is more
about
helping people develop strategies to do
good enough for long enough to get where
they're trying to go and then be able to
sustain it uh so I think for most people
the the stakes and ultimate goals of a
diet are different than they are in for
for bodybuilders and bodybuilding prep
coaches uh and quote unquote good enough
is good enough uh and the the real goal
is that you're aiming to build skills
that will help you maintain weight loss
and you're aiming to find a style of
eating that you would be happy to stick
with for for the rest of your life and
so I think that's I think that's the
lens as a consumer of information that
you should view advice through
um you know something that might be
excellent advice if you could do it for
the rest of your life might also be
advice that you just have no interest in
implementing for the rest of your life
and if that's the case
it's probably not advice that you want
to to implement while attempting to lose
weight because ultimately
you're going to have to drop that and do
something else once you lose the weight
and now it's time to maintain that
weight loss so I think it's generally a
better approach to
um to focus on those things and build
those skills along the way instead of
separating kind of diet life from post
diet maintenance life like you're yeah
it's a process of of finding something
that uh once you get out of the diet
you're perfectly happy to eat the exact
same way you were during the diet are
very very similar with the sole
exception of hey now you can eat a
little bit more yeah yeah I think uh I
think this is great advice the one thing
I would add to it which I assume that
you would agree with is you know we've
talked in recent weeks a lot about
inter-individual variation and response
variability and the the underlying
premise of those conversations is that
different people are in fact different
people yeah and they will respond to
things a little bit differently
um and I know that just from
observations like you and I have very
different dieting experiences yeah you
know the uh the way that we approach it
the things that help us succeed are
quite different
um and so I I would say that for the
vast majority of people
um you know what you're saying here is
is going to lead them in a better
Direction than just the the kind of
standard approach which is oh let me
take bodybuilding advice and apply it to
a much different weight loss scenario
but I would encourage people
if some of these things based on your
experience have helped you
that's okay you know you don't have to
work your way toward the norm if you
have past experience or experiment you
know you've experimented with some
things and found oh I kind of respond
differently than most folks so like for
example
um I've tried to do uh really laid-back
approaches to dieting and I struggle
with them because I've done a lot of
um I've done a lot of reflecting on this
because I look at the literature that
says exactly what you're saying exactly
and I'm like
but it doesn't match my reality and I've
done a lot of uh reflecting on that and
I think what I've come to find is that
perhaps because of my dieting history if
I take a a really relaxed approach to
weight loss dieting
it doesn't get into The Sweet Spot of
goal setting where it's challenging
enough to excite me yeah and so it's not
that I get demotivated by Falling short
of the goal it's that I get demotivated
because the goal is not yet exciting
enough to me it's not as it's not
challenging enough to get my foot in the
door and to get rolling with it yeah and
so like some people might find things
like that or some people might find you
know what for me and the way that I eat
uh you know I'm just really sensitive to
hyper palatable Foods even if I'm not
absolutely shredded and so for me it's
best to kind of keep things at no more
than like a seven out of 10 on that like
hyper palatability scale some people
might find like high protein maybe for
you hedonic eating is not a challenge
during your your dieting process but
satiety is something you really struggle
with and you find that maybe even going
above 2.2 grams per kilogram helps you I
I think it's or it could just meet your
food preferences better exactly yeah
some people just really really love a
ton of very lean protein-rich Foods
I I don't know how makes no sense to me
but those people exist and I'm certainly
not going to tell them they're they're
wrong for that preference yeah yeah so I
just wanted to in the interest of being
fully comprehensive I wanted to leave
that door cracked for people so that
they they feel uh encouraged to
experience their own experiences and
actually utilize that information you
know I I think whether it's training or
nutrition or some of the psychological
elements of interventions it is
important to lean on your own
experiences and take them seriously I I
agree and just to just to add two things
one like to to
just reiterate something I said up top
but to make it very clear a lot of this
stuff is good advice in a vac in a
vacuum yeah but becomes unhelpful advice
if it leads to issues with
implementation but if you've tried like
if you've taken some of this advice on
board implemented it and it didn't lead
to issues with with implementation and
sticking with it long term then it is
great advice in a vacuum and it's great
advice for you you know like you said it
matches your experience works well for
you the other thing I'll say is that
um with a with a lot of your your
experiences like like that you noted
some of the things you found for
yourself that uh seem to comport better
with some of this advice and seem to
conflict a little bit with the
literature I wonder if it's a bit of a
chicken and egg scenario where the the
people
for whom bodybuilding advice like
bodybuilding type nutrition advice
works well and and matches well with
their psychology doesn't lead to to
issues with implementation and adherence
I wonder if those people are just the
folks who are disproportionately likely
to become bodybuilders in the first
place I I was thinking about that
um when I was like well I don't know
some of this stuff has been really like
when I because I have intentionally said
no I'm going to be more compatible with
the literature and take a more chill
approach to my next diet and I just
can't get into it so yeah I do think
that uh I do think that to some to some
extent
bodybuilding is an innate stable trait
of a human being yeah rather than it is
a uh a hobby or Pursuit like I I do
think that there are some of those
traits that are fairly stable and
persistent in me that nudge me towards
certain approaches to dieting yeah I
think it's I mean most
is a whole select for for different
types of people
um you know like it to to be a power
lifter
um there's a certain
there's a certain level of psychosis you
need to have to get very far in the
sport because uh I mean
I'm sure I'm going to make some people
upset by saying this but there are
inherent risks and dangers associated
with the sport that aren't inherent to
all forms of General resistance training
um
like
catastrophic things can happen when you
have 700 pounds on your back uh they're
unlikely to happen they generally don't
happen but when you walk that weight out
like you feel it you know that if if
something goes astray my life could
irrevocably change in this moment for
the worse well yeah and like you know it
like an equipped bench presser yeah uh
many of them are very familiar with what
it feels like when your radius and ulna
are bending start flexing yeah yeah
that's an unusual thing yeah and so it
that the sport selects for a type of
person who isn't just comfortable with
those things but who likes those things
which is which is atypical and so I
think that I think that bodybuilding is
similar like I think it selects for
people with like particular personality
types and particular uh relationships
with with food their own bodies like
satiety Hues and signals all of that
stuff that probably in aggregate differs
from population Norms to a to a pretty
large extent yeah which further just on
a fundamental level calls into question
the utility of
you know just just normal folks trying
to lose 10 20 30 pounds and keep it off
taking
advice that bodybuilders have uh
developed and found to be very effective
for themselves and other bodybuilders
yeah yeah it definitely reinforces that
point and I I think you know your
segment does a good job of saying like
here is
the bodybuilding tool kit yeah and here
is the not bodybuilding toolkit and what
I would and I'm sure you would encourage
people to do is give yourself access to
all the tools right so like a lot of the
people who are really into this kind of
bodybuilding oriented advice say no that
other stuff doesn't work that that's not
serious enough to work and then people
who Embrace these other sets of
approaches might say oh that
bodybuilding stuff way too rigid it'll
never work for anybody the ideal
scenario is grow your tool kit you know
figure out what's going to work for you
but don't feel like just because you're
losing weight or you want to lose weight
that all of a sudden you're locked into
the body to the lifestyle of a
bodybuilder in 1985 with a fanny pack
and the the white and black pants they
need to bring those pants back they need
to bring actually fanny packs are coming
back yeah but I hear people are wearing
them like around their shoulder yeah
that's not the same
it's not a fanny pack anymore it's not
yeah
um all right ready to move on let's do
it cool
um so my segment's gonna be really short
really really short uh and the the the
title here is what is the healthiest
diet
um so I was getting into this a little
bit because
um I was doing a piece for Mass about
just kind of painting with broad Strokes
about nutrition like it if you were just
to give someone a really simple set of
guidelines and say you know what this is
gonna broadly nudge you in the direction
of a healthy eating pattern is this
perfect have we fully solved human
nutrition and optimized it for
performance and Longevity not quite
we're not there you know but we have
learned a couple things and I think it's
important to when possible lean on the
things that we have some decent evidence
for right so
um I was putting together this piece
about like what are some of those
guidelines that can broadly set us in
the right direction with our eating
patterns
um so that's one reason I wanted to talk
about this the other reason is I don't
think it's happening more or changing
all that much but I feel like in recent
months I've been so much more aware of
the arguments on social media of just
like the wars between all these
different popular diets and everyone's
so focused on identifying the one and
only optimal diet for the entirety of
humanity uh that is perfect in all ways
not just in some ways but actually my
way of dieting is best for your brain
your performance your body comp your
long-term Health longevity cardio
metabolic Health even the environment
all of the things are best with my diet
uh and when you see when you see people
making those those
same sets of claims for two diets that
are literally mutually exclusive you're
like what the hell is going on here guys
yeah
um so it's it's harder than that let me
let me note up top as as both your
friend and business partner I am uh both
delighted and terrified by this by this
recent development of you becoming aware
of these things because I remember I
remember back when we met and you were
in grad school and we would talk about
just like Fitness industry stuff you had
a pretty good knowledge of everything
that had been going on before you went
to grad school and then things that had
happened within the last like four or
five years very murky you were a bit
busy guy in the lab all the time barely
on social media not really monitoring
the chatter and now you've you've been
out of grad school enough and worked in
a business that has to be on social
media for for things to function enough
that over the last two or three years
you you've you've started to become
sucked into the Vortex of just the the
dumbest and most ridiculous but also
most entertaining online arguments about
inane [ __ ] related to Health Nutrition
Fitness and uh I'm so excited for what
what the future holds as you continue to
descend down those rabbit holes yeah I
mean so like for context here you know
my brain didn't fully come online
especially in the nutrition world you
know until like the late 2000s which
would have put me in my late teens
basically
um I think that's right yeah so I mean
you know all the stuff that was going on
in the 70s and 80s perhaps it was as
vitriolic and just flatly insane as it
is today I doubt it
um but but yeah then so I was kind of
tapped in in the like late 2000s early
2010s then I went to grad school and
everything happening in the outside
world was just silenced I was just kind
of stuck in the lab uh physically and
mentally and yeah I I've emerged and I'm
just like what in the world's going on
and I will admit I've been clicking on
more things lately yeah and so now all
of the algorithm focused social media
sites are like oh you like really dumb
claims about nutrition
guess what I have a million of them and
they're just flooding into my feed so I
I do think I like I said over the last
couple months but
it's really been over the last few years
but over the last couple months I've
been clicking stuff yeah and and I'm
really seeing the full weight of
algorithmic social media uh and news
feed stuff it's good stuff yeah my news
feeds and timelines and all that stuff
are just getting insane like I'm losing
touch with reality from some of the
stuff I'm seeing uh it's just uh a
dazzling array of just insane claims and
and exaggerations and just flat out
misinformation uh about nutrition so
anyway uh you know like I I feel like
back in the day it wasn't quite like
this where there was like some general
agreement on you know
broadly speaking what a decent diet
looked like yeah and then they were you
know they're of course quibbling over
the details and then maybe uh following
some lines of research that eventually
fell flat you know for a minute there
everyone's like oh this this margarine
stuff seems pretty great we can make
these these trans fatty acids that seems
like a good idea and then eventually
they're like ah yeah about the trans
fatty acids maybe maybe not yeah you
know so um
anyway these days things have gotten
wild and and one of the things that um
really jumps out to me is that
science is incremental and it's slow
it's slow and it's incremental every now
and then you'll have a paradigm shift
that will really fundamentally change
the trajectory of that boring slow kind
of incremental progress
but in the nutrition space right now
everyone is fully committed it seems to
just imploding the Paradigm like I I
can't tell you the number of pitches for
a fringe diet that they they all start
with okay first of all forget everything
you thought you knew about nutrition and
it's like but I don't want to like I
don't think it's a good idea for that to
be the starting point for all
nutritional discourse is forget
everything you believe you you know yeah
I mean if you fully subscribe to the
current scientific consensus really on
any topic but like nutrition included uh
you will probably take on
five percent incorrect beliefs just
because yeah science doesn't know
everything yet uh things are provisional
um and yeah like the The History of
Science suggests that we've been wrong
about plenty of things before and I'm
sure we're we're wrong about plenty of
things right now but
what percentage of our current
scientific understanding of nutrition is
wrong I feel like it's a number less
than a hundred percent so someone's
saying throw out everything there are a
lot of babies being tossed out with that
bath water yeah it kind of feels like if
you were slowly and methodically over
about eight decades working your way
toward the center of a maze and then uh
on a whim you just said
can you take me back to the start I I
just want to start fresh and see what
happens right and it's like you can look
at it from above and be like dude you
were pretty close like you were really
you were really getting there yeah
before you said hey on a whim I'll start
over and try my luck with a different
path yeah so yeah there's there's this
knee-jerk reaction of just forget
everything that people have forget all
the knowledge that has has been obtained
over the last hundred years and let's
just like go on Vibes or you know
strained theories and dude I was telling
you off air I saw a thing you know
people look at these univariate
correlations okay let's forget
everything else in the world exists and
only look at two variables right and you
know you'll see this all the time you'll
say well we'll look at saturated fat
increase his uh intake has increased
since the 80s and look at this
cardiometabolic or obesity rates you
know it looks like they were both going
up at the same time I'm not good or you
know hey look at sugar intake over the
last 30 years and obesity rates looks
like they're both going up
dude I saw one the other day that was
looking at again with a univariate
correlation like this it's basically
saying okay let's just assume everything
else is equal
no other major confounders that we
really have to worry about here
yeah pretty smooth sailing but we'll
just look at these two variables some
nutritional variable and obesity rates
the x-axis started in the 17 I think it
started at the year 1700 and it was
looking at sugar intake in the UK love
that and like you were saying off air
it's like if you're going to look at a
temporal correlation with obesity
just like any instance of
industrialization is going to correlate
with obesity over that time scale yeah
like like virtually anything like so
yeah there's just so many uh insanely
off track posts that you can run into
that's kind of why I wanted to do a
little segment on like so what if we
didn't forget everything we know and
instead just kind of made a short list
of the things that we feel pretty good
about knowing so that's really the
direction here so you know there's all
these diets to pick from
and people that will defend them to the
death uh you know high carb high fat
carnivore vegan Mediterranean the list
goes on and on and on there's there's
these diets that people want to fight
over and always the question underlying
those those conversations is what is the
best diet and I feel very strongly that
that is the wrong question to be asking
I would throw that question out entirely
and I would start from a different
perspective and that is first of all
what are the the major health issues
that appear to be uh quite meaningfully
impacted by dietary habits you know what
are the most pressing health issues that
seem to be very closely linked to
dietary habits and behaviors and and to
me some of the ones that really come up
are obesity diabetes hypertension heart
disease and cancer those are some of the
things that come to mind for me and so
then the second question you ask ask
yourself instead of what is the best
diet for all things you kind of key in
on those if we're focused on health
right so we'll kind of put performance
and stuff aside so we've got this kind
of cluster of uh you know pathologies or
characteristics or whatever these things
that seem to be correlated with uh
negative cardio metabolic Health
outcomes or just generally you know
mortality rates and other health
outcomes
we've got this set of things we're
focused on instead of asking what is the
best diet for all things what kind of
dietary patterns
patterns not diets seem to reduce or
Elevate risks for these independent
outcomes right and so when we look at
for example obesity rates you know and
we say well what kind of dietary factors
or patterns seem to be uh important to
consider here you might look at a diet
and say okay well what kind of energy
density are we talking about uh in what
way is this diet uh supporting satiety
you know satiety and hunger regulation
uh what how many hyper palatable foods
are finding their way into this diet
what we're looking at is dietary
patterns that generally promote uh the
over consumption of total energy you
know so the the term you'll see in the
literature sometimes is over nutrition
just what kind of things within a
dietary pattern nudge us toward over
consumption and a lot of times it does
come back to those factors energy
density satiety regulation and Hyper
palatability with diabetes that was one
of the ones I mentioned
um you know of course over nutrition or
over consumption of energy is certainly
a factor so we would lean on those
previous factors I mentioned there those
previous uh broad dietary patterns
um and other things that come up though
with diabetes is we might specifically
look at to what extent are we kind of
acutely overloading the liver with uh
excess energy substrates not acutely
like meal to meal day to day but are we
having extended periods of time where we
are coupling over nutrition with over
consumption of maybe some key nutrients
that really promote uh the accretion of
fat within the liver itself because I
think a lot of people under appreciate
the role that the liver plays when it
comes to glucose homeostasis but uh the
glue the liver influences many many
different Pathways that are very
critical in glycemic control and so if
you're over feeding and you have low
physical activity those two things alone
are the key drivers and I don't want to
lose sight of that
um but you might also take it a step
further and say well aside from those
two main drivers we might also be a
little bit wary about dietary patterns
that promote really high intakes of
specific nutrients that uh
disproportionately facilitate fat
accretion in the liver and the two that
come to mind would be saturated fat and
fructose that doesn't mean that you need
to restrict both of those to the
greatest extent possible but what it
means is you know if we want to limit
risk for type 2 diabetes we want to
avoid over nutrition and low physical
activity those are by far the most
important drivers but we can also look
at some individual like if you're really
going heavy on the saturated fat and the
fructose especially from added sugars in
combination with over nutrition and low
activity those are the types of patterns
that we might want to keep our eye on
yeah with hypertension broadly in many
cases we're going to be looking at
sodium potassium and some key
phytonutrients that can affect in
vascular and endothelial function heart
disease you know we might be looking at
specific fatty acid intakes added sugar
intake fiber intake and then with cancer
we're looking in many cases at
intake of fiber certain phytonutrients
that that might decrease cancer risk and
then of course carcinogenic compounds
that find their way directly into the
diet things that that seem to have
pretty direct links to the promotion of
cancer formation so uh of course these
are hard to separate entirely you know
because a lot of these fall under the
umbrella of metabolic syndrome and so
over nutrition and low activity is kind
of broadly influencing essentially all
of these outcomes but we can start to
look into little kind of individual
nuances for each outcome and again kind
of ask ourselves not just the name of a
diet that works here but but broadly
speaking what kind of dietary guidelines
and patterns might we be nudged toward
if we were really focusing on minimizing
risk here and this Probably sounds like
it's going to be like a three hour
segment where we go a deep dive into
each individual
um outcome but instead I want to lean on
a couple sets of guidelines that I've uh
been looking over lately that I think
provide a pretty sensible starting point
now
the huge caveat that's going to carry a
lot of weight here uh I'm gonna go over
these guidelines there's two different
tables that have a high degree of
overlap
I'm not saying that any diet that
deviates from one of these guidelines is
a seriously and severely flawed diet
that's not what I'm doing here I'm not
saying that when we put these together
we have the perfect human diet frankly
I've given up on the idea of a singular
perfect human diet humans are pretty
flexible pretty adaptable that's why
we're still here uh throughout all of
the famines in our evolutionary history
we can adapt to a lot and live on a lot
of different diets
um so you know sometimes you'll you'll
hear people say oh you know this isn't
technically an essential nutrient
therefore you should never eat it and if
you do eat it it's bad for you that
that's silly you know humans there are
some essential nutrients we need but to
discredit a dietary pattern because it
includes like carbohydrates that are not
technically considered an essential
nutrient it's nonsense it truly doesn't
make any sense so what I'm going to talk
about here are some guidelines I do
think it's funny that that
same logic like if that's what you're
saying like if something isn't necessary
you don't need to consume it at all
I've never seen someone apply that same
logic to non-essential amino acids yeah
but like why shouldn't it apply you know
yeah no it it's
um it's a convenient way to discredit a
dietary pattern that includes something
that yours does not yeah it's it's the
type of thing where if you throw it out
to an audience that doesn't really have
their guard their guards up it's sound
it sounds really uh
insightful and impressive until you
think about it for three seconds yeah
and then hopefully you have continued
talking enough that people won't think
about it for three seconds because
they're thinking about the next thing
yeah exactly so what I'm going to talk
about here is uh a couple sets of
dietary guidelines that
again it's it's kind of a la carte you
know cafeteria style when I'm putting
together a dietary pattern and
establishing eating behaviors and habits
what I want to try to do is check some
of these boxes off so this is not a
concise list that leads you toward a
particular named diet this is just
things that like ah it would be nice if
your diet checks a lot of these boxes or
it you know we shouldn't really treat
them as dichotomous either so if for
example you're supposed to get 400 grams
a day of something and it's like okay
well I usually get about
320 well that's better than 100 right so
it's about these are some guidelines to
shoot for you want to get close to them
if you can and ideally get close to many
of them you know and check off as many
of these boxes as you can so
table number one that I'm looking at
here I'll put it on the screen these are
the healthy diet indicator criteria uh
from the World Health Organization uh
and I know uh some people
the World Health Organization isn't
necessarily your direct Pathway to make
people say okay now I can let my guard
down I know a lot of people have said a
lot of things about the the who in
recent years uh their Q rating I guess
isn't as high as it used to be uh a q
rating is like a term that they'll use
in like uh various places like how do
people generally view you like your
general Good Vibes uh to to an audience
yeah yeah so yeah people have been uh
really critical of the World Health
Organization and in some very
specific pockets of the population I'd
say yeah for uh
I would say for a combination of of
deserved and undeserved reasons and I
don't want to elaborate beyond that yeah
so what I want to get at here is
regardless of the organization you don't
want to just say well I'm going to turn
off critical thinking and just because
any particular organization says
something yeah I'm not gonna you know
I'm just gonna blindly accept all of it
but in this case uh it's a set of
criteria that is extremely compatible
with the best available evidence and
nutrition it's a really rigorous set of
criteria that I think uh leads you
toward a really nice eating pattern and
for the record I have I currently have a
high level of trust for the World Health
Organization I I think they're doing
their best and generally doing a decent
job but anyway uh table one here uh
fruits and vegetables you want to be
aiming for over greater than or equal to
400 grams a day total fat you want to
limit that to no more than 30 percent of
total energy saturated fat no more than
10 percent of total energy
polyunsaturated fats aiming for six to
eleven percent of total energy uh free
sugar or like added sugars less than 10
percent of total energy dietary fiber at
least 25 grams a day
and potassium at least 3 500 milligrams
per day
now people are going to look at that uh
in a variety of different diet
um
groups you know people who are kind of
really strong proponents of a particular
diet there's going to be some elements
they love in some elements they hate so
for example if you're someone who's
really
um really adamant about ketogenic diets
you would look at total fat less than 30
percent of total energy you're not gonna
like that I'm gonna be pretty annoyed by
that but you might look at free you know
added sugar less than 10 of total energy
and say well yeah that that makes sense
that's sensible
um so it's important to recognize I'm
not saying that like no one can be
healthy on a ketogenic diet right but
but this is kind of a list of just
painting with broad Strokes what general
dietary patterns seem to be associated
with really positive outcomes in terms
of mortality and just broadly cardio
metabolic Health uh so that's the first
table the second table that was from
2015. that was the the set of criteria
uh looking at 2020
there's an updated set of criteria I
can't really tell based on the paper if
this is necessarily like from the World
Health Organization or if it's just a
research group who said I we want to
propose some 2020 updates to it but in
any case I I do think it adds a couple
little boxes to it that that are that
are pretty sensible so
um the the scoring for for these three
things is just greater than zero grams
per day which just means hey try to eat
this stuff yeah it's generally
associated with some nice things uh and
those categories are beans and other
legumes uh nuts and seeds and whole
grains and broadly speaking when you
look at the observational literature and
you combine it with randomized
controlled trials uh dietary patterns
that feature these uh in you know
relatively moderate to to high amounts
seem to seem to do pretty well right so
that's why the the uh the recommendation
is is greater than zero grams it's like
try to build a diet that includes some
of these things it recommends limiting
limiting dietary sodium to less than two
grams a day so less than two thousand
milligrams it recommends zero grams per
day of processed meat
which qualitatively Speaking just means
um probably don't eat processed meat if
you do you know try to limit that to the
extent you can and then for unprocessed
meat it says less than 71 or less than
or equal to 71 grams a day very oddly
specific number but but what they're
generally getting at there is hey you
know there's there's other protein
sources that are not neces or no I said
unprocessed meat it should be
unprocessed red meat yeah so that that's
actually a big flub that I made there so
they're referring specifically to
unprocessed red meat with that limit of
less than or equal to 71 grams per day
so again broadly speaking what they're
doing is looking at the literature in
aggregate in its totality and saying
okay these seem like generally good
boxes to check when you're putting
together a relatively healthy eating
pattern
um and again we don't want to approach
this super dogmatically right so for
example with sodium
that's going to be one that gets people
pretty riled up because right now
there's a pretty big contingent
especially in the fitness space saying
like you know what your biggest problem
is you're not having enough sodium and
you need to have salt like before your
workouts and stuff
um and then there's another contingent
that's kind of more from the
conventional Health literature saying it
seems like you know in populations where
there's really high sodium intake
hypertension seems to be a prevalent
issue and for a large percentage of
those folks reducing sodium and or
increasing potassium seems to very much
help with those hypertension outcomes so
with sodium it gets complicated because
there does seem to be a some diversity
in terms of genotype where some people
are more sensitive to Salt than others
when it comes to blood pressure and
hypertension so some people will
increase their dietary sodium and it
really doesn't affect their blood
pressure much at all some people
increase their dietary sodium and their
blood pressure goes up and they might
have higher risk for hypertension and
there are even some people who uh they
almost have like an inverse relationship
where if they are at their normal level
and they drastically minimize their
sodium intake their blood pressure
actually goes up uh which is which is a
bit odd
um and so I I don't think it's
easy to do like a one-size-fits-all
recommendation for sodium and then of
course I mean you start talking about
athletes who compete in or or train
train and compete in hot weather and you
know they're losing a lot of sodium in
their sweat so their sodium needs are
kind of influenced by that so again
we're not not putting these guidelines
on a pedestal and being super dogmatic
and saying you need to check every
single box regardless of context but you
know like I was getting at earlier I
think when it comes to putting together
a healthy dietary pattern we want to
just kind of lean on what seems to be
the consensus of the best available
evidence like what things do we have a
pretty good handle on currently when we
look at long-term cardio metabolic
outcomes and mortality outcomes and when
we kind of put these two tables together
we start to get a really nice set of
dietary criteria that we can broadly
view as compatible with favorable Health
outcomes to what extent you wish to
adhere to any particular one of these is
totally up to you like I'm not here to
get in an argument with someone who says
well I like to eat way more than 30
percent of my calories from fat that's
totally fine what I would say to that
person
and a lot of people are in that position
ketogenic diet does have some very
sensible applications
um but what I would say is okay you want
to have 70 percent of your calories
coming from fat that falls short of one
of these boxes
um but where's that fat coming from you
know maybe maybe then you say okay but
you know I am limiting added sugar I am
eating plenty of uh you know
very fibrous low starch vegetables so
that I'm getting fiber and I'm getting
my vegetables every day uh through that
maybe I'm getting plenty of potassium my
fiber is adequate you know what what I
would encourage people to do is not say
there's one Criterion on this list that
I hate therefore I'm throwing out
everything yeah you know the purpose of
this you know you might say I I don't
really like beans and legumes fine but
you you can still you know adhere to or
or strive to meet some of these other uh
quantitative objectives and it will
probably be fairly compatible with some
nice Health outcomes you know so you
don't have to to buy the whole list or
sell the whole list but it is a set of
criteria that broadly nudge people
towards some pretty uh pretty Health
compatible eating patterns so broadly
speaking what we're looking at here when
you start to just condense it more
qualitatively is plenty of fiber which
broadly speaking seems to be a really
solid thing for for a variety of Health
outcomes
what I would call a suit a suitable
intake of both potassium and sodium and
this is one of those things if you're
like listen I don't think I'm
particularly sensitive to sodium in the
diet I don't want to worry that much
about potassium and sodium you know
either their absolute amounts or their
relative amounts compared to one another
for those folks I'd say at bare minimum
just keep an eye on your blood pressure
you know if you start noticing that
you're getting into the pre-hypertension
or even hypertension range of course I'm
not a doctor you know so this isn't
medical advice but if I started to see
my blood pressure going up I'd go and
chat with a doctor and say what's going
on here and they might say hey why don't
you try limiting sodium and see what
happens you know there might be a
variety of different routes you can take
there so if you're someone who doesn't
want to get really particular about
potassium and sodium I totally get that
I know a lot of natural bodybuilders who
they're like hey I just noticed that I
eat seven grams of sodium per day is
that bad and that's kind of high but I
mean you know their blood pressure is in
a normal range they're they're not
having any adverse cardio metabolic
indices that that can really be observed
and they're keeping an eye on those
things and it's like well then I don't
know do what you want to do yeah that's
kind of the boat I'm in I I'm it uh
probably yeah probably like six seven
grams of sodium a day yeah like you're
like you're describing
um the issue I have if anything is
getting hypotensive
um and even even when I was up near 280
uh blood pressure was like 110 over 70
and it's it's lower now which is
unfortunate yeah um that's crazy that's
really low sometimes stand up and get
all woozy but yeah but yeah so uh but
yeah if I was it
if my blood pressure was like 140 over
90 or something
um then I certainly would cut back yeah
or at least you know get with a doctor
and say what do you what do you
recommend as a first line of action here
and I I expect they probably would say
let's look at probably sodium if not
both sodium and potassium and just try
to get those in a more
more uh comfortable balance based on
what your blood pressure is telling you
yeah
um so yeah the broad Strokes here high
fiber a suitable potassium to sodium
intake
um usually blood pressure is going to
help you kind of figure out if that
needs to be acted upon plenty of fruits
and vegetables you want to minimize
processed meats and charred meats you
know you don't uh eating charred meat
that um
you know there have been some studies
saying yeah maybe not ideal for gastric
cancers
um red meat in moderation you know I'm
certainly not saying that you know
people should eat zero red meat but
broadly speaking when you look at the at
the literature It generally tends and it
Trends in the direction of of saying uh
maybe in moderation you know
uh the the long-term Health outcome
literature for example for like fish and
poultry seems to be a little bit more
favorable than it is for red meat
especially fatty cuts of red meat
um you want to eat enough protein to
support lean body mass of course which
doesn't necessarily take all that much
as we've talked about previously
um uh maintaining a reasonably High
ratio of polyunsaturated to saturated
fatty acids seems to do pretty well in
the literature I know a lot of people uh
have essentially built their entire
personality around uh fighting that
recommendation like if you were to go
out and say hey like polyunsaturated
fats pretty good saturated fat might
want to limit some people will just
absolutely lose it when that comes up
but I mean the literature isn't really
that hard to parse with those outcomes
it it looks pretty pretty
straightforward like I wouldn't say like
yeah I mean there there have been both
observational uh lines of evidence and
randomized controlled trials where
managing that ratio of polyunsaturated a
saturated fatty acid preferably nudging
it toward the higher range seems to be
pretty good for blood lipids and cardio
metabolic outcomes uh total fat intake
you know not too low not too high that
that's where a lot of the research
generally nudges you toward and then
saturated fatty acaturated fatty acids
capping those at less than 10 percent of
total energy broadly speaking seems to
be pretty compatible with with the
research
um you have something to say I I do just
just one one thing to point out that I
find kind of funny
um so you you mentioned uh people who
who just like really push back against
the polyunsaturated to saturated fat uh
stuff and also just just people in
general who have uh Fringe nutrition
ideas that are very much not supported
by by the literature
um like one thing to note uh that I I
think most listeners are probably aware
of is that a lot of the research in
nutrition
um specifically for long for long-term
Health outcomes comes from either like
either like observational
epidemiological studies or like cohort
studies there aren't you know there
aren't that many like 30 40-year rcts
where you say
I don't know if there are any but yeah
like it's not like there are a ton of
studies where you say like Hey we're
gonna we're gonna have one group eat low
saturated fat one group eat High
saturated fat for the next 30 years and
just observe the outcomes and like
they're definitely going to stick to
that
um because yeah like that's that's not
how how humans eat
um like people aren't going to want to
sign up for a study where researchers
are controlling their diet for the next
three decades so uh people with with
very heterodox uh nutritional ideas will
point to the research that does exist
and be like oh you're making the classic
blunder
um you're drawing causal inferences from
observational research uh which that
part in in a vacuum is is a fair
critique and then they'll take the next
step and say and in fact
these things that healthy people seem to
do
it is actually bad for their health but
because people are telling them they're
healthy like they're doing these things
but also like a lot of other healthy
behaviors and so ultimately you're
dealing with with a case of healthy user
bias where it looks like the things I'm
promoting are associated with bad Health
outcomes looks like the things uh the
World Health Organization uh
uh like the EU similar body like similar
body in the US like it seems like all of
the things they're promoting are
associated with good health outcomes but
you know what turns out you can't
believe any of that stuff because it's
all just observational research and uh
actually you should just only live on a
diet of raw red meat yeah but the the
thing is
then they'll they'll come back with
claims of like and guess what carbs
they'll kill you uh all seed oils and
things with uh high levels of omega-6s
they're poison they'll kill you
vegetables guess what they'll also kill
you but it's like
I have a hard time
understanding how you square that with
the critique of observational research
and healthy user bias because the thing
is if those things are so bad
you still have to contend with the fact
that the folks who do who eat that way
still do have generally positive Health
outcomes like right there there is an
upward constraint on how bad and
poisonous those things can be you know
yeah unless you're contending that like
if those people were just eating the way
I told them they would live to maybe 150
years old yeah you know like yeah it is
so someone tried to like drag me into a
debate uh which is always the best way
to do it uh just a online debate where
two very confident people yell over each
other and cannot fact check each other
in real time that's always the best uh
someone said I should debate this person
and I said like we have such
um
severe
gaps uh such a mismatch
in terms of the way we view epistemology
just what levels of evidence we find to
be convincing and compelling and like we
we can't even agree on like broadly
speaking what is the hierarchy of
evidence for nutrition and what counts
as very credible nutrition evidence and
based on that there would be no utility
of doing a debate uh and and it was it's
kind of like hey let's play this sport
um but we absolutely will not agree upon
the rules before the match yeah we'll
just go into it you'll be playing one
sport I'll be playing a fully different
version and we'll just like kind of
figure out how it went after the fact
yeah
um but yeah I mean there there's so many
instances where you'll see people saying
yeah I mean sure there's all this
evidence that that shows that at bare
minimum all these things are are really
really compatible with with great health
and and you know excellent long-term
Health outcomes
um but I want to throw that out because
have you seen this in vitro research you
know or I eat very differently and sure
enough I am right here and alive so how
do you explain that yeah um yeah there's
just like there's just this General
rejection of you know really high
quality epidemiological research and
nutrition
um
rejection you know well the rcts are too
short the the epidemiological stuff is
too observational the cohort stuff they
didn't really control it that well even
though it was a you know a cohort based
intervention over several decades so
like let's just bring it back to the
petri dishes and just assume that I can
learn more from a mouse with
fundamentally different metabolic
characteristics than I can from 20 000
humans who were involved in a a
prospective cohort intervention yeah um
I don't know what to do with that so
like I'm certain that they're going to
be a lot of folks that hear the segment
and say uh this Trexler guy is an idiot
because has he seen this mouse study and
ignored all the relevant human evidence
and yeah there's some of these battles
that just really can't be won in the
short term and uh
it is what it is but uh now that we've
discussed some of these broad Strokes
um
kind of basic eating patterns and kind
of guidelines that seem to be most
compatible with the current evidence
inevitably people are going to say yeah
but give me a diet give me a named diet
that works and is better than the rest
I don't want to do that but I will say
there there are multiple named diets
that generally check off
uh plenty of these boxes right so a
couple that come to mind this isn't the
whole list but two that come to mind I
think the DASH diet tends to be a pretty
sensible diet I think if you don't have
hypertension there might be some
constraints in there that are not fully
applicable to you
um so I'm not saying it's the perfect
diet for all people but the DASH diet
tends to do pretty well uh the
Mediterranean diet tends to do pretty
well I know a lot of people then come in
and argue very aggressively about what
the Mediterranean diet truly is
um I'm just going off of the
intervention studies and the set of
characteristics that have broadly been
embraced in the literature to this point
so for example uh stuff you eat on the
Mediterranean diet plenty of whole
grains legumes fruits vegetables healthy
fats herbs and spices I read that quote
from uh an image here before people just
absolutely tear me apart for using the
term healthy fats but broadly speak
they're talking about fats that have a
lot of unsaturated fatty acids and
relatively low saturated fatty acid
content the stuff that is you know still
pretty heavily emphasized but not quite
as much as the others we got fish
other seafood and foods that are rich in
omega-3 fatty acids uh poultry eggs and
dairy still part of the diet but not not
quite as as highly emphasized and then
things that you would eat sparingly
would be things like red meats and you
know sweets with a lot of added sugar
when we look at the DASH diet again
plenty of vegetables fruits whole grains
uh low low-ish fat dairy products fish
poultry beans nuts seeds vegetable oil
stuff like that things that you would
limit on a dash diet or that kind of
eating pattern would be fatty Meats full
fat Dairy sugar sweetened beverages
sweets and you know really high added
sodium intake
um you know people again are gonna go
nuts and say well there here's this
study on full fat Dairy that says it's
fine I'm not saying that these eating
patterns are I'm not saying that every
guideline in here is fully necessary for
every single individual but these are a
couple dietary patterns that brought
broadly speaking are pretty compatible
with those broad guidelines from the two
uh the two healthy diet indicator sets
of criteria that I mentioned previously
yeah just saying like if if you're very
insistent about having a named diet yeah
these these seem to be pretty good yeah
they seem to be pretty good but most
importantly the the key Point here is
that these are not the only two options
there are plenty of Cuisines around the
world that are very much compatible with
these broad sets of eating patterns and
eating behaviors so like I know one
thing a lot of people say is that some
of these um
some of these named diets often tend to
be used in a way that
kind of excludes major portions of the
world you know it just kind of
recommends like particular food items
and like you know sometimes you'll see
like here's a sample meal pattern and
you'll find that it is it's very
um
it's not very compat compatible with
different Cuisines around the world uh
and just you know different
um you know spices and food sources you
know they tend to get very regionalized
and say okay everyone in the world
ignore your cultural traditions and eat
just this set of foods right and that's
not necessary there's plenty of Cuisines
around the entire world that could be
fully compatible with these types of of
eating patterns uh with you know just
little modifications and little bits of
effort here and there to incorporate
certain food items so um yeah I'm not
saying you know everyone has to eat
these two name diets these are two that
come to mind that are pretty well
studied that check a lot of the boxes
but I mean I've been eating a lot of
different uh
you know as I've kind of transitioned
into a more plant-based eating pattern
I've been eating a lot more Asian
Cuisines I've been eating a lot of
Chinese food thai food Vietnamese food
Indian food
um and yeah man it's great but but it is
kind of kind of eye-opening I used to I
used to eat essentially just shredded
chicken for every meal and like just nor
just eating like kind of the the very
generic sets of vegetables that come in
the American supermarket and to me I'm
like eating all these Foods I'm like
I've never heard of this in my life but
but they still broadly allow you to
check a lot of these boxes you know yeah
you seem to be very tickled and I don't
know why no two things one just you
your your mention of uh eating a broader
variety of foods one of my favorite Eric
interactions of all time was uh one time
when you came over to work and you just
had this gleam in your eye you said Greg
have you heard about cumin that was that
was one of one of the better starts to a
work day I've ever had I came in like I
um was like a music Insider with my ear
to the ground it was like dude something
just dropped yeah like cumin is out and
and
have you heard of this did you know it
was coming like yeah it'd be like if
somebody dropped a new album and I was
the first person that heard yeah yeah
yeah so that that was uh that was my
first my first thought the first thing I
found a little amusing second thing uh
mentioning that you've been eating
eating more uh Asian Cuisine uh more
like Chinese food more Indian food Etc
uh this is this is
um slightly tangential to health not
exactly what you're talking about but
since we're since this is somewhat a
segment about uh uh difficult to defend
Health claims that people make online uh
one of the one of the ones that just at
its most basic level I find uh
quite quite humorous
um is people claiming that like
vegetarian and vegan diets uh in
particularly diets high in soy and low
in animal products animal fats are just
like catastrophically bad for
Reproductive function
just like look look
at the scoreboard yeah exactly exactly
if if you just if you just pull up a
list of of where are there a lot of
people where does it appear that people
have
been really successfully procreating and
what do they eat yeah um
you know I think that uh
that is observational evidence if
someone wants to throw that back at me
I'll take it on the chin but but like
come on but again come on the claim that
you're making is this eating pattern
tanks fertility right yeah up it doesn't
take that much observational research to
at ver at the very least nullify that
claim correct like yeah if you're
telling me this dietary pattern is
incompatible with fertility it I don't
have to clear a high bar to disprove
that yeah
um yeah so so wrapping things up here
and the reason I bring up the different
Cuisines though is I know there's been a
movement within the uh the dietetics
profession
to just be a little bit more culturally
inclusive because what they kind of
observed like in American dietetics is
that everyone was coming in and a lot of
diet this isn't a knock on dietitians
because they identified that this was a
practice that needed updating but people
were coming in from all different
cultural backgrounds with all different
cooking experiences and Cuisines and
everyone was just being sent home with
like have you tried white potatoes
broccoli and chicken breasts and they're
like
I don't eat this [ __ ] yeah like this is
not
I've never known people that eat the
like this is not how I eat like can you
meet me not halfway can you meet me an
eighth of the way in the middle here and
so like it is important to kind of just
acknowledge that very very different
cultural traditions and and Cuisines and
things like that they can all be
incorporated in a way that that meets
some of these broad criteria yeah
um you know people will
I can already see comments coming in
thank God as we've covered in previous
episodes I don't read on them but yeah
wow but what about seed oils being
catastrophic that's an unsupported claim
it just is uh what about gluten causing
all sorts of problems for people who
don't have celiacs disease or
sensitivity of broadly speaking to like
high FODMAP Foods again it's it's an
unsupported kind of line of inquiry that
people have taken mostly to sell books
uh what about carbs being the root of
all cardiometabolic problems they're
just not
um it's not hard to disprove that in a
pretty convincing way uh well Eric you
don't talk about biohacking and fasts
and things like that there's a reason
for that because it's unsupported we're
we're just looking at the distilling
from decades and Decades of nutritional
science what are the things we feel like
we can really hang our hat on here
um what about the plants being poisonous
not going to entertain it it's a silly
idea uh if you really want to make the
claim that eating vegetables is a
potently deleterious Act
you have no value for
research
and and therefore like that conversation
is a non-starter because I'm going to
lean on the research of actual Health
outcomes in humans and if you really
think that eating vegetables is a severe
Hazard To Human Health I I truly don't
know what to tell you yeah uh and again
the the idea that for example
all animal-based protein being unhealthy
that also is an unsupported thing and I
I I'm saying that as as a vegan you know
like I I'm trying to play it just by the
book here looking at the literature I
don't currently eat any animal-based
proteins but I don't have to go around
and say well actually they're absolutely
catastrophic to your health just to make
myself feel better
um you know like I said there is some
evidence to say yeah it might be
worthwhile to limit certainly processed
meats and then you know maybe also like
fatty red meat in moderation right but
the the literature pertaining to poultry
and fish is excellent you know and I
don't have to justify my own biases by
making untrue unsupported Health claims
you know yeah so um yeah just be careful
out there folks there's a lot of stuff
in Nutrition a lot of different dietary
kind of Pockets out there of really uh
really enthusiastic proponents who want
you for some reason to throw out decades
and decades and Decades of incremental
scientific progress and I would at the
at the bare minimum just encourage you
to resist that urge to uh like I said
that that example with the maze maybe
hesitate before saying yeah let me take
me back to the start and I'll just try a
totally different path and forget
everything I learned along the way yeah
um
so you know do we know everything with
nutritional science of course not you
know we don't have enough we don't have
a fully complete picture we cannot draw
up this and say this is the optimal
single human diet like I've said
previously I don't think that even
exists I think that's a bit of a Fool's
errand
um but the stuff isn't that complicated
to the extent that that you should say
well is it possible that we truly don't
know a single thing about human
nutrition so people will try to over
complicate and you know misattribute
blame to certain nutritional components
they're largely doing that to just open
up a little space a space kind of create
a niche for whatever angle they're
trying to take but what I would
encourage people to do is just focus on
Broad eating patterns try not to focus
on demonizing individual nutrients or
individual food sources and when we look
at the broad eating patterns that are
compatible uh with you know supporting
Health longevity Etc we are starting to
work our way toward a nice uh concise
little list of of patterns and behaviors
that seem to be very compatible with a
healthy diet
yeah one one thing I guess that I would
add is
I so I have
um
I have nothing but disdain for most of
the people who uh who put forth and
promote uh a lot of these pretty uh
pretty unjustifiable
um perspectives on nutrition
but I I will say that that I and and I
assume both of us have uh quite a bit of
of empathy and understanding for people
who would get sucked in by a lot of that
yeah
um
I I think that there's
you know I think it it makes sense to
look around and say uh especially in in
America uh which is where around half of
our audience is located and I mean a a
pretty disproportionate chunk of the
most out there nutrition folks are are
American and I I uh I think there's
probably a reason for that but I I think
it's it's easy to look around and say
well you know there's
science seems to have improved Our Lives
in so many ways and like Advanced so
much like you know people aren't dying
from communicable diseases at nearly the
rates they were a long time ago
um
like a lot of of medication has improved
like treatment of heart disease uh has
gotten way way better like that kills
way fewer people than it used to
um cancer treatment seems to be
improving on the tech side of things you
know compare computers today to
computers 30 years ago seems like
there's so much progress being made
um but it seems like in spite of a lot
of external markers of progress
um just the General Health of a lot of
people uh
seems to be kind of trending down or
yeah I mean like you you look around and
there's there's a lot of of very
unhealthy people out there
um and it it doesn't seem to comport
part particularly well with the advances
we've seen in in other things
and I think it's easy to look at that
and then look at
um you know some of the some of the
worst excesses of the industrialization
of food production uh all of like the
the hyper palatable hyper processed
foods on the shelves
um and just kind of
kind of
find yourself in a position where
it feels like uh
it feels like something is just is just
wrong with with food like there there
has to be something to miss for us to
find ourselves in the position we're in
um you know given the the broader uh
progress we're seeing in you know
basically all other domains like what
what's going on there and so I I think
that
um you know I think that a lot of that
is like very multi-factorial
um but I I think that like single Factor
thinking is very seductive because it
can give you
it can give you a sense of control and
it can give you a feeling that hey if I
can just like control and manage this
one thing like I can I can take control
of my life get everything back on track
um like it's it's in it's a easier
narrative than trying to look at like
all of the different underlying causes
of things going on and the solution
also presents itself as being easier
than you know like hey let's completely
redesign American cities so that you can
walk and cycle more and be more active
and you know maybe be a little healthier
for for that reason like let's uh try to
transition away from fossil fuels so air
quality is better so I if you have
asthma you can go outside without
hacking up a lung like you know like the
the like big structural problems are
more challenging to tackle and I I think
that by and large like the American
political system has has proven itself
to have little appetite for tackling a
lot of those things and so
um I don't know like all of it can just
make you feel like you're you're going
crazy and just lose losing control of
your life and when you find yourself in
a situation like that a
Silver Bullet type solution that at
least like purports to have really vast
and Powerful explanatory power starts
being very appealing and seductive
um and so like I I absolutely understand
how
consumers of that information kind of
get sucked down those rabbit holes and
and find it uh convincing or or at least
alluring and placing
um so I I have a ton a ton of empathy
for for folks who who find themselves in
those content spaces but
um yeah I I just encourage you to uh
um
I don't know just just take a step back
and look at things a little bit more
critically yeah I know I I totally Echo
that uh I think it's
very understandable to be in a position
where you're ready to embrace some of
those ideas and uh I think it's really
easy nowadays to be exposed to those
ideas in a way that's very very
convincing and compelling
um which I I understand but also just
generally view to be unfortunate you
know but um yeah I I I certainly don't
fault anyone for getting drawn into some
of those narratives
um and like one of the things that
always comes up along those lines like
you're kind of getting at this with what
you're saying but like I've seen so many
people on the internet who it's like
they have embraced uh a pretty
compelling sales pitch for some very
heterodox like very Fringe nutrition
idea and their response to it is you
know if you say well like look at these
guidelines that are pretty broadly
embraced by like every major health
focused organization
across the world it's not like one
government is just kind of setting the
rules here you know if you bring up that
kind of argument
a lot of times it'll be like
oh yeah great that goes into the dietary
guidelines and look look how far they've
gotten us like like the US government
dietary guidelines yes and to that I
will also I will often say
who do you know
who doesn't I'm not I'm not talking
about adherence who do you know who can
currently
state
the government dietary guidelines
almost no one in the general population
even knows what they are aside from just
general Vibes which is vegetables are
nice
uh and don't eat as many desserts like
that's pretty much the extent to which
the the general population knows the U.S
dietary guidelines and then ask yourself
of the people who know them who applies
them right and so like the idea that you
can say well here's the guidelines
here's the population level outcomes
looks like the guidelines aren't working
I mean that doesn't it kind of implies
or assumes that people are actually
following those guidelines and all of
the empirical evidence would tell us
that they're not correct you know so
that feeds into a lot of that
conspiratorial thinking of like you had
your chance to set the guidelines and
look how far it's gotten us well the act
of setting a nutritional guideline is
not really the helpful part it's the
adherence to a set of dietary habits and
behaviors and you can make the argument
that perhaps
maybe there would be some utility in
reframing these various eating patterns
in a way that would make adherence more
likely I think that's a very strong case
you could make but the idea that because
obesity rates are high or you know heart
disease type 2 diabetes whatever outcome
you want to focus on because those are
high necessarily the guidelines are
flawed that that if you just interrogate
that argument in and of itself it
doesn't hold up it it fully breaks down
um so yeah I I Echo your sentiment like
I I think it's unfortunate that folks
are making these very superficial
arguments that draw people in I I think
it's unfortunate that some of those
arguments on the surface level do do
seem to be quite compelling and
ultimately I have a lot of empathy for
people who are being led down a road
that is ultimately somewhat deleterious
to their health
um and without really knowing it or sign
signing up for that you know yeah and
then one other thing I just want to
reiterate
there's going to be folks who are like
hey my dietary pattern that I prefer
doesn't really uh mix well with with all
of these criteria that's completely fine
like I I have no like no interest at all
in trying to dictate how people eat
um I just try to put out information
that seems most compatible with the
evidence like there's going to be people
who are really healthy
who say Eric I'm on a ketogenic diet and
I'm you know deviating from several of
these items
but I love the way I eat and all of my
metrics right now would indicate that
I'm in good health
if you expect me to be upset about that
you fundamentally misunderstand my
incentives I don't want people to be in
poor health so if you're in great health
and not adhering to all these guidelines
I am genuinely happy for you uh but the
purpose of guidelines is to say okay if
we put 30 million people on a diet and
we had to kind of give them some check
some boxes that they should strive
toward checking these are the broad
brush Strokes you know the the general
guidelines that they ought to be aiming
for based on the evidence that does not
preclude in any way the possibility that
there are people
who deviate from these regularly and are
experiencing really good health at the
moment so
um that that's not the intention I know
a lot of smart folks who are on you know
ketogenic diets that don't check all of
these boxes but are still really well
formulated diets you know like uh I
think a lot of people assume that if
you're on a ketogenic diet you basically
just eat like
uh Philly cheese sandwiches without the
bread all day and that's like all you
eat right uh just beef and cheese and
and that's it
um I know a lot of folks who are you
know on ketogenic diets they eat a lot
of fibrous vegetables they have some
nuts and seeds in the mix like they
actually do check more of these boxes
than you might think so so I don't want
this to be the type of thing that uh
becomes like a diet Wars like I don't
want to put gasoline on that flame and
fuel more of it
um but what I would encourage people to
do is if you have a dietary pattern that
you really like but perhaps you are
unsatisfied with your current health
status or you have some concerns about
um you know your current diets
compatibility with some of these
guidelines you don't necessarily have to
overhaul every behavior in your life and
immediately start from scratch you might
just consider saying okay I'm gonna work
toward getting a couple of these
additional guidelines met within the
broad uh eating pattern that I currently
only have okay so the purpose here is to
be helpful and to lead people toward
evidence-based guidelines not to
disparage any particular dietary
strategy or to make people uh angry
because their preferred method of
dieting doesn't you know check every box
all right so I think that does it for
this episode uh we went a lot longer
than normal but that's okay no big deal
how far are we here uh about about two
hours 40 minutes cool yeah that's more
than I expected that's okay though yeah
that's fine
um that's what the audience likes we're
we're the only two people in this entire
equation who actually want the episodes
to be shorter yeah yeah that's true so
hey there you go you're welcome
everybody uh so hopefully people get
some helpful stuff out of this this is
one of those episodes that isn't like
walking through like 30 individual
studies but is more just uh pretty
applied I would say pretty applied so uh
hopefully this has been helpful as
always we sincerely appreciate everyone
for checking this episode out
um and we will be back in about a week
with another episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast if you enjoyed the
podcast be sure to sign up for our free
newsletter to get concise breakdowns of
relevant research as well as 28 free
training programs for all skill levels
and all schedules we hate spam just as
much as you do so we'll only email you
when we have something really
interesting to share with you
can sign up for the free newsletter at
strongerbuyscience.com newsletter or
just go to the stronger by science
homepage and click the free programs
button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]